oh hey what's up uh i'm dave klein aka
dave control
welcome to eldon ring i am so excited to
be playing with you guys and that
everyone's gonna get to experience the
game tomorrow because it is amazing
um like tam i've been playing for a
while now although obviously i'm gonna
be doing a new game and i'm gonna do
something fun for you guys uh i'm gonna
try to grab
a great sword and like find that
immediately so we can do a gut style run
aha from berserk and see if we can do
that so what's up everyone uh let's hop
into it and i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead
and shut up while the intros playing by
the way so you guys can hear the
cutscene and everything and hey ah
nightmare how are you doing
so yeah i'm gonna shut up for a moment
just for the cutscene so oh i guess i
have to make my character
um
yeah so i'm super excited for this
again since i'm doing a guts build i'm
going to go with vagabond um comes out
about six hours for pc really or where
are you at i thought it came out
friday on the 25th
i didn't i was not aware
uh okay so here are the different
starting classes which people have
brought up at this point as well as
bandai namco
so i'm not gonna go over it too much so
i'm gonna hop in choose a vagabond
and let's
see
hi
i am dave
wait actually no no no no no
no no no no no we're going to be guts
guts
all right
let's okay so for the keepsake let's
talk about this real quick
isn't this releasing in six hours i
thought it was releasing on friday the
25th but maybe like there's something
i'm not aware of unless you're just like
here at a different time zone than me
since i'm in la so i'm on pacific time
uh okay so
let's see
uh if as far as
your keepsake goes
the thing that you definitely want to
choose here is golden seed just because
all of these are things that you can
find throughout the game there's nothing
like specific in this particular game
that you can't find otherwise
the stone sword key is kind of like from
dark souls 2 if you remember ferris's
lockstones kind of acts like that a
little bit where you find
various areas they can unlock with these
special things but you'll find a lot of
stone storage keys eventually so you
don't need it unless you want to enter
like early on in a specially unique area
that's probably way too high level for
you anyways and you'll find storing
store keys anyways golden seas though
are limited and golden seas are going to
upgrade how many estes flask uses you
have so that's why you really want to
start with this one so we're going to go
golden c i didn't do that on my other
game because i didn't know and i wish i
had
yeah six hours for steam damn i didn't
know that that's awesome i guess i'm
more of a console players that's why i
didn't know i'm so you guys are aware
i'm playing on ps5
uh all right so
definitely going with vagabond hell yeah
all right
i'm gonna shut up for a moment and let
you guys watch the intro and yeah i'm
playing on ps5 uh bogdan all right
intro time
by that i mean loading
the fallen leaves
tell a story
the great
elden ring
was shattered
in our home
across the fog
the lands between
now
queen america the eternal
is nowhere to be found
and in the night of the black knights
godwin the golden
was first to perish
soon
america's offspring demigods all
claimed the shards
of the elden ring
the mad taint of their newfound strength
triggered the shattering
a war from which no lord arose
a war
leading to abandonment
by the greater will
oh
rise now
he tarnished
he dead
who yet live
the call of long lost grace
speaks to us all
[Music]
fear
[Music]
all right
so this intro is a little different
in that obviously it's demon souls like
and that you get the images the other
thing is those are also lowly tarnished
like you
that they're referring to though they're
those aren't the bosses of the game so
those are npcs
whom grace would again bless
a tarnished of no renown
i love the voice sector for the intro
to the lands between
to stand before the elden ring
and become
the elden lord
all right
so
i like the intro a lot even though i
know it's not like a cutscene it's the
images just because the voice actor
really makes it for me uh so a couple
things what is special about this game
and have you beaten this game i have not
been in the game i'm at the end game
area you could say um i'm about 80 hours
in so
i'm close but there's so much psy
content i'm trying to do and fine that's
why i haven't beaten it
i could have beaten it a while ago
basically i'm at the end of the game i'm
just trying to like go back and find
everything that i haven't done
uh because there's just so much is
there's so much to explore and do
uh hold on i want to i'm in the wrong
area i want to check my equipment and
see what my rolling is like
i'm a heavy load i don't want that there
we go medium load okay
um what's so special about this game so
i don't know if you played souls games
before but part of what i love about the
game is the weighted combat feel and
this is all their games in general i
think this is
if it's bleeding the audio is bleeding
through to my mic by the way let me know
so i can turn down my tv
but um
he's too dramatic he's dramatic in the
exact right way and they're dude they're
jaeger jaeger there are so many bosses
in this game it's unbelievable how many
bosses there are
so i've been capturing gameplay for
gamespot and for all the videos that
we're going to make and it's like i have
a separate folder of all the bosses and
i was like oh you know they'll probably
be like 20 30 like previous souls games
maybe a little more it's like insane how
many bosses are in this game
um so you're definitely gonna find at
least one that gives you a lot of
trouble first one here is uh
scion
which is your intro level boss for the
game
and uh he's
i honestly think he's the hardest of the
intro bosses
i don't think i don't know i i'm going
to be excited to see when people
actually beat him uh because i
definitely cannot beat him unless i just
need to be like super duper duper
patient
there's basically only one move that he
has that i know i have time to run in
and hit him during
and he hits he kills you in three hits
and you have no healing yet
and you barely do any damage to him as
you'll see when i finally do get a
hidden
so i think you just need to be like
ultra ultra ultra patient if you want to
kill the grafted scion here
um
don't worry though there is a way to
come back here but i'm curious what you
get if you beat him early on i really
want to know if it's like something
different okay
yeah cuz like he he kind of just keeps
on going that's the thing is like a big
old moveset
okay yeah see like even there i thought
i had time yeah there you can see how
much damage i did which was
very
little all right here we go there's
something i can actually hit him
during
so
i'm sorry that this is going to be slow
but while i'm while i'm trying to see if
i can do this to him because i actually
haven't pulled it off yet um
because the intro is kind of long so i
don't always feel like going back
through to see if i can beat him
um while i'm seeing if i can
why the game is so special
is uh for me it's this weighted combat
that i love about these games the weed i
just love this weighted combat deal okay
this is the one i know i can get a hit
in so want to get him for that
um
oh [ __ ] yeah see that was one hit one
more hit and i'm done one more hit and
i'm done
um the weighted combat in these games
just makes the combat so much more
exhilarating to me the fact that you
really aren't just given an easy way to
win uh-oh oh
i like the fact that fights are a little
more stressful in these games because
unlike a god of war say
or other popular action games you
actually feel the stakes of battles and
you don't feel ultra
powerful
so it makes every victory all that much
more sweet and for me that's what i like
i like feeling that satisfaction of
being like oh my god this thing's
actually terrifying
i might really lose to this
and then the satisfaction when you
actually do beat it so
uh is the steam version bad
i don't think so uh i played it actually
i played it briefly on pc
on a steam version and it ran okay for
me
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh
i got greedy i should have just waited
more
why aren't you locked on uh i actually
don't like locking on all the time it
depends on the boss on facing and the
way i'm facing them
for this particular boss i don't think
it makes
sense i'm gonna shut up again there's
another cutscene
hey evan
how are you doing
first time calling i love it evan is
hilarious uh evan's another game spot
guy
he's got the best jokes you need to put
those in videos
it's actually a really good funny
comment
all right
don't worry torrent
fortune is on his side
we found him here after all
one of his kind is sure to seek
the elden ring
uh even if she does violate the golden
order
i'm gonna talk about the lore a little
bit too uh just like some brief things
but like
okay so alejandro says you should always
lock on i don't agree at all you
shouldn't always lock on uh i've been
playing these games for a long time
sometimes it makes sense sometimes it
doesn't to me uh i think sometimes you
play better without locking on or at
least i do
how did you get it early uh i have a
review copy that i've been playing for
the past week
so
uh well that saves me money i hate
soul's comment everyone was trying to
say it would be different in this game i
don't think anyone said it would be
different in terms of the combat i think
people were saying it's going to be
different in terms of like
making the game more accessible by
different ways you could play like it
makes it easier to summon people in for
co-op you get spirit ashes and things
like that
it still has the souls combat feel so if
you don't like that it's not for you
down there the cave of knowledge is the
tutorial area i'm going to just skip
that thing because we don't need to go
there in general when you find these
trees i actually this is the screen for
you guys when you find these trees
that's really important so uh you
definitely want to find those things
and
okay something else that i want to say
can you sheath your weapon yes you can
uh here
sheath there you go i mean so yeah
sheath shield
uh something also i want to say about
the lore is that the point of the game
is to become the elden lord that's kind
of what you're giving right away but
like others uh from software games you
really want to question like
why
do i want to really and why and what
does that mean what is that really going
to do and who's telling me to do it and
why and what is their motivation which
is what i love about these games is that
the more you dig into this stuff it's
like
are people lying to me
is this really a good thing is this the
right thing to do okay so see this guy
remember how you can get a storm stone
sword key as your starting thing
that's what this would do is let you go
through here the boss through there is
uh rough for beginner i don't recommend
it
all right this is all online play stuff
okay
i played ds3 safely with shield and
store but i wonder if i'm losing on
variety i'm not playing offhand spell
two-hand sword i'm a big two-hand sword
person that's how i like playing these
games
or two-handed weapon i bounce back and
forth between decks and strength
personally i've never been super into
spells but that's just
that's what's fun about this stuff is
the variety
uh i don't think there's power stances
do you have to commit to a spell are
there any effect if you offhand them
with the two-hand sword i'm honestly not
sure i haven't played too much uh
sorcery yet
uh i think you have to commit to
spelling those sense of like as is
casting but once you're done i think you
can do what you want and then you can
switch to a weapon if you want you're
pretty free with your builds here
uh something you're gonna want to do is
rest at three sites of grace right away
this guy actually no i've never tried
attacking him
i wonder what happens guts it would
attack it no he wouldn't just would not
attack him even comprehend
gravity of this
if you choice
kindness for frailty apart
then perhaps
a more physical lesson is in order
all right
i don't know if anyone's actually tried
to attack me right away but i'm just
like curious to see
because i've already uh white mask
various name that's good for me to know
actually
he's actually not too hard
what is his weapon it's like roses oh my
god okay there's a church of roses in
the game and later you find him at the
church of roses so that makes a lot of
sense he would attack with roses okay
that's so funny as a bouquet of roses
he's attacking with
uh i don't really know if he's a good
character or not yet i haven't really
figured that out to be honest
but um
yeah you know
let's let's start by uh attacking our
first npc that's how you play these
games
oh oh oh oh uh i think if i remember
correctly he's actually against the
whole wait a second he barely does any
damage to me because he's hitting me
with roses
i didn't even realize that
okay
now i feel bad for attacking him
actually
oh
oh
okay that's this thing
gonna try to cause some blood loss okay
let's back away and
i was like just letting him hit me
because i didn't care made in this rut
okay so that's what he says
[Music]
festering oh you don't get his uh roses
that's too bad all right so there's no
good reason to kill him now we know guys
now we know
is this single player uh
kind of it's like single player but you
can summon people in to help you out or
you can go attack people
oh something okay so there's a couple
things that we're going to do here
for one i'm not going to be using fp
very much so i'm going to uh
i'm going to change so i have more
healing
right there by allocating that and then
because we have a golden seed
now i get an extra charge to my crimson
tears so now instead of four i have five
charges so that's what the golden sea is
going to do for you the next thing we're
going to want to do really fast is go um
we're going to go run and activate two
more sites of grace because that's going
to allow us to level up and get my steed
and that means i can go get the great
sword
i wonder what the max for flask is i
honestly don't know the answer to that i
haven't found all the golden seas yet on
my own
save or my main save
can we play now or do we need to wait
for the midnight release like sadly i
think you have to wait
uh souls that bore an expert but i
completely ignored bleed damage build up
i saw it building up i just didn't
realize it was doing that much to be
honest
uh so sorry
for whatever reason i wasn't paying that
much attention to the bleed build up
my bad
forgive me
um
yeah if you don't know my channel or
anything by the way uh hi i'm dave
control i've been making
souls videos for
eight years at this point
so
there you go
uh what gp do you have i'm playing on a
ps5 right now so
uh unfortunately i can't tell you like
how it's running on a ps5
so
hope that helps oh what was i going to
talk about before
oh i want to see the what he dropped
with the roses but he doesn't drop
anything
something uh right away that you're
going to want to
do uh i am carly
wait do you say i'm after his throat
i am telling where the land has been
it's only tarnished like yourself let's
say you're a very welcome customer okay
anyways
you pretty much want to torch right away
in this game
you actually do need it this time around
and here you have a smithing stone for
upgrading your weapons but
right now i think i only have one so we
can't do much with it
i'm gonna go ahead and off hand my
the torch
oh the other thing that's nice in this
game
quality of life stuff is on the right
hand side of the screen it shows that
equip there right hand side equip load
medium load light load it'll just tell
you so you don't have to like kind of
like play around and just roll to see
what it is
can you show the merchant items sure let
me go back and show you sorry about that
all right so what is it the merchant
sells
throwing daggers
uh telescope which i want to go back and
buy
uh for calling finger remedy
so that's uh going to be for multiplayer
crackpot for crafting
crafting kit is going to be how you
craft things uh so you're going to want
to buy that from him as well so i should
go ahead and get that
uh the various cookbooks he sells are
for crafting these are basically your
recipes for crafting things
a couple arrows the torch which like i
said you really do want right away
a large leather shield
and then he sells the chain set which
doesn't really have too much lore to it
and
a couple of um
basically these are little tidbits of
helpful info so the flask of wonder is
physic is that you pronounce it
um
so the flask of wonderful wondrous
physic this is basically going to give
you a tip for how to find it which is
another healing flask that you can find
that's more customizable where you can
find ways to customize your flask as you
play the game
uh and then a note about waypoint runes
which i think just says that there's
like a dungeon or something so but you
can't read what those say unless you buy
them
is there an early version apparently
power stance is always on if you wield
two of the same weapon
oh something else that you can do by the
way is you can dual
wield weapons like in dark souls 2.
uh so if i left hand a weapon i could do
that if i want i'm just not doing it at
the moment
uh okay so see that guy right there that
i activated what that's going to do is
if you look at your map right here it
actually shows you the direction
to
a dungeon
and right here we don't have our map yet
but what you can see right there is even
though i don't have it if you uncover
that foggy area with that that's where
mac fro map fragments is located
so that's kind of like a good thing
right off the bat
playing eleanor watching dave play on
the ring humanity restored thank you
night artorias hey coming from artorias
that's the best thing that i could
possibly hear
uh and speaking of which artorius is
based off of guts and i'm going to try
to do a guts run uh as soon as possible
here
is this kind of like destiny style uh
destiny is kind of like soul style uh in
terms of its multiplayer so destiny was
actually directly inspired by dark souls
and how it did
its multiplayer and demon souls
so in a sense yes but like really it's
uh
it is dark souls in style
eldon souls eldon souls oh
foot catacombs once you're in one of
these smaller dungeons like this by the
way you can't warp out so see how
warping is deactivated
um just as a heads up
and this is the area that the person
pointed out to me oh also two endings
kind of weird in this game you have to
press triangle and then r1 to switch so
that's going to be different this time
around as opposed to just tapping a
button it's a combination press
and here we have our first ambush
as it is a souls style game
all right yeah come come to me bro
did you get uh early release access yes
i've been playing the game for about a
week now so um i've been playing for a
while and i'm about
close to eight i think i'm like 75 hours
in for my main game and i still haven't
finished it although
honestly i'm at the end of the game
basically but i'm trying to explore
because there's just so much this game
is massive
uh which is great which is a good thing
not in a bad way it's just you know
in an overwhelming kind of way
for uh
for like trying to get videos done
do you hate sekiro you forgot to mention
your everything to no video no i don't i
actually i love sakiro so i'm sorry
sekiro is that's the proper non
pronunciation i actually really love say
kyoto if you go to my uh personal
channel you'll find that i have a bunch
of videos on it
uh i didn't forget to mention it i was
only gonna list dark souls demon souls
in bloodborne because that's more what
this game's like
this game isn't like those other two you
know we can just actually run past this
they'll probably die at this area
um oops
i actually really like secure i just
added kings field in because i love love
kings field so it's really just for me
as a i love king's feel sort of thing
so that noise was this fire killing uh
one of those goblin guys i just used it
to kill that
the praline paint hello is like your
co-op thing where you can start to like
talk to people throwing these guys down
also fun thing about these dungeons if
you hit this that thing will lower so it
lowers the trap
although the trap was useful for us in
that instance oh [ __ ] why did i go all
the way out there
that was stupid i forgot about this one
uh but yeah i really i actually love
seguro so i'm sorry if it came across
like i didn't like the game i actually
like it quite a lot all right you can
see a trap right here in the waiting for
us but luckily
um we can
kind of manage the trap a little bit
first and yeah these guys caused bleed
as you can see the build up in the
middle there uh way to manage this is
don't pick up that item that's the trap
instead we'll knock out some of these
guys first
and let me uh this guy's gonna drop down
as soon as i attack that guy i believe
so
oh
okay i forgot about the other one
i still got hit by the trap
nope nope nope nope nope nope i'm almost
that bleep [ __ ]
i thought i had my shield out
yep
i'm embarrassed to be honest
you only lose experience when you die
gear doesn't drop right so
did you ever play salton sanctuary from
uh dave langer i did
yeah dave i did i really like salt in
the sanctuary also i'm sorry about the
death i'm embarrassed i love how you put
kingsville on the end of the list gotta
represent your wall checking expertise
thanks existing dark and hey good to see
you man
um
yeah i just i love king's field that's
really all there was to it oh okay so
these are summoning pools
basically this is gonna be like an area
for summoning to make it easier to find
co-op if you want to do co-op stuff
so that's what that's for
all right let's just go ahead and run
through now
how is this so far slash worth it it is
get good yeah i know i know
i know i failed i need to get good
uh whoops you know let's pop this back
up actually so if anyone's coming after
me you can help me out
so
the game is incredible it's it's
definitely uh
tam gave it a 10 out of 10 per game spot
as a review in progress and yeah i
i agree i don't know if it's my favorite
souls game if i'm being honest because i
just love the inner connectivity of
bloodborne and dark souls and the way
that works
but um
only i had something that i could use
for them to like attack them from far
away
we'll just at least somewhat deal with
this
you know what maybe i can use this to my
advantage here actually i'm gonna have
these guys run into it
there we go that's the way to deal with
it
there's the way to do it
um but like dark souls and bloodborne
are two of my favorite games of all time
so
yeah is the valkyrie fight good also
what's your favorite boss i actually
haven't gone to the valkyrie fight yet i
think that's one of the really later on
fights or i just haven't found it yet
because i'm like 70 hours into the game
and i haven't gone into it so i don't
know
um
show us the spectral mount i haven't
gotten the spectral mount yet you get
the spectral mount after resting at
three slice of grace which i'm about to
do
wait can i play right now i think in
five or six hours for steam and the 25th
or midnight for uh console
is it hold on i just gotta make sure i
didn't get a work message i did not okay
uh is it just one difficulty or do you
have a choice it's one difficulty but
the thing is with this game you can
explore so much at your will that you
can really level yourself up in a way to
make certain areas easier
uh inside like you can really explore
side dungeons like this you can roll
around and like kill enemies with your
horse once you get it
so you can make the game easier for
yourself but it is one difficulty and
the one thing that i think is important
to mention about it
is that um
even though it's one difficulty if you
are a souls that type of person
it's not easy it is not easy and like i
think the end game area is like it's
kind of like you're it's you know it's
the end game area so it's going to be
hard no matter what or whatever
difficulty because you can't really
level up beyond that
and even then there's like there's stuff
that i found where i was like oh my god
this is this is tough
uh
okay here's your first well the first
spirit ash i'm getting i'm not gonna use
them and you can't use them yet anyways
because you need a special item that i
haven't gotten yet to summon spirit
ashes but basically those are help that
you can call in
and i never use them so that's like
another way you can adjust the
difficulty for some people who want it i
personally don't like using it i like
playing these games and the thrill of
trying to fight things solo i never play
co-op with these games
uh that's just how i like to play
personally but you know that option is
available if you want it so
it's worth pointing out
this is gonna open up our first dungeon
boss
has this patch changed the performance
on ps5 honestly the performance was fine
on ps5 before so i i haven't noticed the
difference since i got the patch
but i just got the patch yesterday and
i've been playing for about a week so i
i haven't noticed the difference but i
thought it was playing fine before
all right here's our first boss
yeah and if you don't want spoilers
don't watch this please and like look i
love the game and i kind of recommend
that as much as i'm
part of it's like my job to say watch
this but also from my heart i say don't
spoil yourself really if you don't want
um i mean it's up to you
but i like i like the mystery and
intrigue of these games so if
that's for me like part of the thrill is
not knowing what's going to happen
yeah that's kind of like a fast reaction
for that specific attack from this guy
oh so this guy has an expanded move set
from what we saw before
yeah so when he as soon as you see him
twitch he's gonna attack there so that's
what i was like watching out for
yeah he actually doesn't expand and move
set from
from the network test the network test
all he did was this like floaty attack
and now he does a little bit more so you
know that's that's interesting
oh [ __ ] hey
[Music]
yeah so since he's my first boss and i
haven't leveled up at all he's gonna
probably be the toughest one here
or one of the tougher ones in a sense
just for the sense of him being the
first one
but he's really not that bad
here to give a thumbs up and i'm out i
thank you for that i appreciate
who said that ign i don't know what
you're sorry i'd miss that so i'm
curious about said what
uh i've seen people like debating if
this game's hard or easy by the way and
here's what i'll say
is that
it's kind of both
i mean you can definitely make sections
easier but i promise you we'll get to
fights that are like
brutally difficult if you want that and
you can stick to it and try it so like
okay see i'm gonna stop
uh targeting him for a moment just
because it's easier to run around him
oh no why did i do that okay
i thought like i got greedy during the
next hit that was gonna screw me over
all right we get some more ashes here's
another cool thing about this game by
the way there are so many dungeons in
this game everywhere you explore they're
cool things to find and there's unique
dungeons like some of them start to look
similar like you find a catacomb it's a
catacomb but the design is gonna be very
unique you can tell that they really
cared about how they crafted it
and there's always a boss at the bottom
and sometimes there's something totally
unique
you can't really predict it
uh what the boss is gonna be
and there's always some item that you
get from the boss so it's like there's
always going to be something that you're
getting so that's really cool
uh it's just yeah it's pretty damn
amazing
okay actually i'm going to warp back
here just to get some estes flash
charges for the next area we go to
what is this game about from uh pm or p
mitch studios
uh basically the the very basic plot
line is that a bunch of demigods
have these great runes that prevent them
from dying and someone steals the rune
of death
to make it so they can die now and kills
one of them and murders one of the most
important ones
and after he has died uh the elden ring
and people start warring over these
great runes that make them powerful all
these demigods and it destroys the world
basically
and someone
is sent to become a new elden lord to
restore peace essentially and like rule
over everybody
and you who are tarnished who have been
cast out for some reason probably
related to definitely possibly i don't
know
um
but it could be that that's my guess um
you've now finally been sent by somebody
you don't know who you don't know what
their motivation is but somebody
to uh
wake up to go become the elden ring and
rule over everybody and become the elden
lord
uh voice of video game says like the
chalice dungeons and bloodborne uh kind
of except these aren't randomized they
feel more thought out
um definitely more thought out honestly
uh geraldo flores says it feels easy
because so many of us are used to harder
controls and harder gameplay
what kind of weapon are there oh there's
tons and tons of weapons there are some
really weird weapons i mean like most of
them have like a specific kind of weapon
class but there are so many different
weapons in this game
so like
there's like daggers
like short like basic swords like this
heavy swords super ultra great swords
which is what i'm gonna go for in this
playthrough
um
and just like
lances spears
weirdo weapons that have like prongs
everywhere twin spears um
weapons i don't even know how to
describe it because i feel like i'd be
spoiling them things with flames on the
end you know it's like there's so many
different unique weapons
anybody want capcom to announce dragon's
dog matu instead of street fighter
i'd say yeah just because well i don't
know i'm happy that's another mainline
street fighter honestly the fact that
it's street fighter 6 is pretty exciting
and that they don't do the numbered
stuff very often makes it more exciting
you know
um but
i mean hey it'd always be new nice to
see another dragon's dogma
all right so this camp i'm gonna be a
little more sneaky with just because i'm
pretty low level
and i want to make sure that i uh
don't get murdered because there are
some guards here who will call everybody
onto you
and there's one specific enemy who's
pretty tough while you're low level
his swords for op like in dark souls i'm
honestly not sure
francis marcus says try neo i'm not sure
if he's talking to me or anyone else or
maybe that's for the um
the people saying they want a dragon's
dogma too neo is really good by the way
i really like neo
uh it's
kind of like a cross between ninja
gaiden and
dark souls which
i mean that's pretty much intentional as
that's
it was inspired by dark souls literally
inspired by dark souls they saw the
success of dark souls and kind of
modeled it after that and it's by team
ninja who made ninja gaiden
so that's why you get like a mix of the
combo feel and everything
it's a really good game
i definitely recommend neo although
again it's different so
kind of depends on what you like and
what you want and i just let that guy
see me which is probably stupid
don't see me don't see me that's the
tough night in this area
i mean if he sees me that's fine but i
want it to be alone oh good i got a
smithing stone okay
i'm just trying to pull him away
yeah this guy's like the tough one all
right let's pull out my shield
why you got a glint in your eye golden
oh [ __ ]
already doing bad
all right so what i just did right there
was like your special shield attack
thing you see i barely did any damage
anyways so it doesn't like op it at all
it just can make it so
you can uh sometimes it can cause get
let you get a visceral on someone and
stun them
oh no i oh god i got another guy out
here okay that's not good
uh okay is the deluxe edition on steam
worth it or the standard edition good
enough if you've never played this type
of game i honestly don't know what the
deluxe edition comes with so you'd have
to ask me
i'd imagine that there's no reason
unless you
want to
they're usually pretty good with these
games about not giving you stuff that's
like game breaking or anything like that
like usually the extra items are kind of
like fun stuff that's more like
fun to have but doesn't matter that much
when they do that sort of thing for
these games but i i can't tell you
crap i'm just gonna try to roll through
to see if i could backstab him
this is the true first boss of the game
yeah
oh crap crap
i sort of rolled forwards i was going
the wrong way
ah
impatient right come on
i do so little damage maybe i should
just two-hand it instead
yes oh he did the visceral thing to me
all right come on boy come on boy
no i was trying to go around for a
backstab
while we're whittling away this guy's
we'll start
oh
yeah let's hope that doesn't happen
oh geez already got me with it that time
come on come on big boy let's get you
no
oh my god
oh here we go backstab got it okay
there we go all right now that this
guy's down the rest of the camp will be
pretty easy
although we got a couple dogs to worry
about
right that's one doggie down
sorry dog
i guess it's a wolf does that make you
feel a little less bad no
dogs are really like the true
dark souls they're so much harder than
any other enemy
just so aggressive and hard to hit
all right here we go one more
i saw something about cyberpunk in the
comments which i'll check in a moment
all right
this camp is basically down
okay
do you have to parry a lot in this game
you don't have to appear at all if you
don't want to i mean it's fun too but
you don't have to i've been paused i
don't want to see the game before 9 p.m
that's fair
you welcome some bro what's up abdullah
my fellow sun bro
uh what class is he playing i'm playing
vagabond to answer the question for you
guys
um
i know i'm a little biased but these are
honestly some of my favorite games of
all time and i think this is i think
eldon ring and like i said i'm about
like 75 hours into it
uh i honestly think it's one of the best
games i've played in like
years i'd say the last game i played
that i loved this much personally it was
hollow knight
uh okay so the smithing stone that i
just got here let me give you the item
description i'm just rolling through
this stuff because i'm like i want to
get my guts built going but i should
show you guys some of this
all right uh smithing whetstone knife
uh basically allows the uses of ash of
war decisive grace to bestow new battle
arts and affinities to armaments and
skills so this is gonna be the way that
you equip your ashes of war which i
think did i just get one yeah i just got
ash of war storm stomp which i'll show
you guys and go ahead and equip to my
weapon
can you still forge weapons out of
boss's souls yes you can
and something else i want to mention i
said this in the beginner's tip video
that we just posted a game spot um
that i think is pretty important
is that
you can actually duplicate your boss
holes this time around by finding a
special area all right here's our first
map fragment by the way so now we can
see one little bit of the map and i
press i'm telling you this is a very
tiny portion of the map
uh when you zoom out even that doesn't
really show you the scale of the scale
the scope of the map
uh okay so
you can kind of start to like look for
points of interest just by looking at
the map like ooh what's this thing
ooh what's this thing
that's like one way to look for points
of interest some of them are a little
harder to find like there's a cave over
here that you wouldn't really find on
this map
uh oh whoops anyways
that's the first map fragments
all right over there's another set of
grace i'm going to activate in a moment
i'm just going to finish exploring this
camp first because i've wiped out just
about everybody who's at it
uh okay
i guess it's not elden's news after all
oh another thing i'll say is like i know
everyone's been hyping up this game and
in my opinion like it really lives up to
it this definitely from software is one
of the companies like nintendo where
like you kind of just know everything
that they make is going to be ultra high
quality it's always going to hit that
quality bar and they never disappoint in
my opinion
all right i gotta head out and get ready
for an appointment all right later
existing dark thanks so much for joining
all right there you get another new
weapon a flail
how many times can you respect total
switch region to new zealand and play 18
hours early oh hey hopefully that works
i think i read you can have up to three
others in co-op i'm honestly not sure as
i never
play online in that way i don't like to
do co-op so i can't tell you
uh oh so it's not pause when the map is
on no it is not paused when the map is
on the game never pauses so even when
you do this as you can see game is not
paused um and i also constantly auto
saves so
you know there's that too all right the
lord's sword and greatsword lord sworn's
greatsword this is what i was using a
lot in the early game
uh so you can see the strength
requirement there i don't have enough
for it but i have enough to two-hand it
so two-handing will not be affected but
i'm gonna start leveling up same
strength a bunch because i want to get
that uh ultra grit sword baby
is this game better for ps5 or siriusx i
don't know the answer to that i'm just
pref i don't have a series x i have a
ps5 so that's what i've been playing it
on
dark souls 4 eldon ring ah honestly it's
so different i wouldn't i think that's
unfair to say
i think people have seen the melania
cutscene so i'm going to go ahead and
skip it just to show some more gameplay
so sorry guys skipping melania
have you heard of have you heard of the
finger maidens they serve the two
fingers offering guidance and tarnished
and aid
to the tarnish
but you
i am afraid
i can play the returning route to aid
you you need only take to the foot
okay so she wants to get taken to the
foot of the archery i don't know what
happens if you refuse i'm honestly
really curious but i haven't uh
you know i'm gonna do a run through just
to see what that is because i'm curious
but she gives us the spectral steed
aspect
has chosen treat him with
our our good boy torrent
okay next thing we're going to do
your thoughts let's raise strength all
the way up actually i'm going to give
myself one endurance so i can start to
have endurance affect your max equip
load let me show some of this actually
okay so endurance is going to be max
equip load stamina and some defense for
now but it doesn't always raise your
defense eventually actually erases your
body which is interesting that that
changes i didn't realize that it
originally does defense
vigor is going to be hp and physical
defense so it's all defense
mind is also giving me defense right now
oh there you go as you can see when i
level a couple more up it starts giving
me body
uh that also takes a while to give me
body but that's going to give you more
fp
strength is for strength build weapons
um dexterity's for dex weapons
intelligence
um
is for magic faith is for magic arcane
is going to be for your discovery and
also just give you various defensive
boosts
uh like you can see like magic fire
lightning
again i'm gonna go full strength and uh
one endurance so
that's gonna be the set
uh
any difference in console uh versions uh
are so nice like negligible yeah i'd say
at this point probably unless you get it
like on switch which they don't have
where do i recognize your voice from
uh well uh my personal youtube channel
is dave control so maybe one of my
videos on there
uh that's likely otherwise i've hosted
for a few networks before gamespot where
i work now
so
yeah i don't know
i can't tell you i've been at a lot of
places but my guess is my personal
youtube channel dave control
all right so here we go we got our boy
torrent
and it is time my dudes
to go do some exploration and uh uh i'm
gonna see if i can equip the great sword
okay for now i'm gonna throw i have the
lord sword greatsword on you can see
that i can actually equip it properly
now
uh but for now and actually let me see
if i have a heavy load oh i am heavy
okay
let me take off my helmet then okay not
a medium i don't know if the great sword
is going to work in terms of my
heaviness but that's okay oh [ __ ]
whatever i'm just finding the next side
of grace
is fabric 50 or 75 percent equipment you
know that's a good question let's go
find out right now i actually don't know
the answer to that
is there a new game plus i don't know
i honestly don't know
uh how do i play now i don't think you
can i think you're gonna have to wait
for five hours unfortunately okay so
let's see
i'm at 33.8 out of 51. if i add the
helmet that puts me on a heavy load at
so i guess it's closer to 75
because yeah half would be
26 about 25 26
so yeah i guess heavy roll is at about
75 percent
[Music]
okay let's go use our torrent first
thing we're going to do is find a np
do i want to ruin that
and
you know what you can't find this but
i'm just going to show you this because
it's hard to find
oi
you you there
could you help us out kelly
who
who where
oh i didn't know i could just roll into
him for that i used to
swing at him
all right this is my boy bach
oh yes some claw you were just breaking
thank you the name's bach
i was pushed out of the cave cytograph
is a bonfire yes
are there a number of twin blades in the
game the different twin blades scale
different stats there are a number of
different twin blades i haven't been
using them so i'm not sure
if they have different stats
when they throw me out of them so this
is all i am i hope
all right so he's giving me a mushroom
thank you but he's going back to a cave
by the shore
so we're gonna try to find that cave by
the shore eventually
but that's uh yeah
oh there is this special boss here is
it's night time i'm probably gonna get
wrecked by but you know what i'm here so
might as well try it oh
hey torch cool
oh yeah here's oh i forgot to quit my
ash of war crap oh well
i could have like given my self a little
boost a nice cavalry boy
oh crap
great good start me
i accidentally jumped up porn i do that
a lot where i accidentally press the
button for it
oh no oh no there's extra enemies here
great
that's not what i want
i'm more worried about the extra enemies
than i am the nice cavalry here so there
are some bosses that only appear at
night and this is
one of them
uh i found multiple bosses that only
show up at night time so that's where at
least i can tell the day night cycle
matters
all right
let's let him do his leapy attack
other thing you can do right now are
wanting it
uh also various weapons act differently
on horseback
you see that's like my r2 and it does do
more damage and actually it's sometimes
worth it for boss like this the only
thing is that sometimes i only hit his
uh steed when i do that which is why i
don't always use it against this guy
i got him there it's pretty good
you know i'm gonna go ahead and heal
right now just because he can knock me
off my horse pretty easily and then just
correct me
nice cavalry boy
crap i was hoping to get him there
so horseback battle does take a little
bit of time to get used to but once you
do get used to it
it's a lot of fun and it's definitely
different it feels different so that's
another unique thing about this game
yeah the reason i don't think it's fair
to say this is dark souls 4 is that the
open world just makes us so different
and feel in a lot of ways and also like
the horse and everything is just such a
totally new mechanic
the jumping and stealth you could say
is like okay you could add that to dark
souls 4 but i just don't think it's fair
also it is a brand new world so i mean
like it's a totally different story
so that as well
uh but yeah obviously mechanically it
has different similarities you can say
the same thing about bloodborne right
crap i'm not doing much damage to him
i'm just hitting his horse
i mean this fine
if you you kill the horse you knock him
off of the horse but he can't call it
again
so
that's the thing is like that's why i
don't care too much about
oh wait i wanted to target him
where is he
oh also the other thing is he'll
disappear if nighttime ends so
try to kill him a little faster if you
can
yeah i'm pretty low level oh geez oh
geez okay
i'm a little low level to be fighting
him right now i think
to be honest but that's okay you know
oh boy
at least i reached like some levels up
before i went to him so like it'll be a
little better and i haven't upgraded my
sword at all
even though i can do it now i'm just
trying to see if i want to
okay the reason i'm not standing next to
him too much is he actually does a good
deal there of uh damage if he hits you
so really it's just like a chance to get
a few strikes on him as you saw
and then yeah he summons his horse again
but it's like similar to you right like
if
people can kill your horse and it knocks
you off of it and then they can get a
really heavy attack on you
so
that's basically what you're doing to
him there and then he summons your his
horse again
if your horse dies you can use an estes
flask to call your horse back and
basically like you
recover your horse also you heal your
horse by using an estus flask so
sometimes there i was using my estus
flask more so to heal my horse than heal
myself
it was really for that reasoning
hey i got him all right
uh yeah you're right about that long
week bro
repeating thrust of war
nice
i don't think there's any settlement how
do you get more flasks you need to find
golden seeds which i'll show a little
later
uh okay so where do i want to go now i
guess like i'll continue going this way
for now since i'm already doing that but
i am gonna go get an ultra heavy sword
in a moment
hey their troop isn't with them
so i think to get that you need to
actually exit uh or stop them from
moving so you can get the item in there
it's not what it was in the network test
all the items are completely different
okay there we go got him knocked down
these guys can actually be kind of
difficult uh
when they're chained up like this they
aren't this isn't the true
representation of their difficulty
because they don't have a blade with
them and they're
they're being uh used to slaves here
but yeah like they they actually can be
pretty tough
uh oh also you can level up weapons
pretty high too so when you start
leveling up your weapon don't think it's
gonna like overpower you immediately or
anything
because yeah there's like
so much
usually he gets sad when you kill his
friend so let's see if he goes and gets
sad
wait where's the where's the thing they
were carrying what the hell
what just happened
oh no
i think that's a glitch
there's a trade-off between crimson and
uh cerulean
yes there is it's just like dark souls 3
in terms of estes in that way
all right let's go to uh pumpkin head
who i'm probably gonna die against now
because uh
i can't believe the carriage disappeared
that's kind of annoying
these guys are the band that usually go
with the garage so
yeah i've had like
one glitch that's happened to me a
couple times where i like try to enter
my horse
in a spot that you're not supposed to
and then like i just get frozen
but that's about it in terms of glitches
for me
wait why aren't even attacking these
guys i don't need to do that i want to
go to pumpkin ahead
he's here somewhere
i don't think this game will be her
ryzen forbidden west on game of the year
on playstation uh
this game is definitely beating horizon
forbidden west
this is a hands-down game of the year
there's like no chance that any other
game has i think this isn't this game is
a masterpiece i'm just gonna put it that
way
it's it's a total masterpiece
unless you absolutely hate souls combat
uh
do you think this game is easier or
harder than other from soft games i'd
say it's a little more difficult
like you can make it easier i guess
maybe just the way i play
feels harder
because of the way i play
again that's just
very much personal for me
but i'd say
that yeah it's probably going to be a
little more challenging
don't mind the fact that i'm wrecking
these guys
uh i don't know you're just gonna get to
a point where some bosses are just so
tough
there's some really really hard bosses
in this game um let me tell you so
i think that this game overall is more
difficult even though you have more
options than ways to play granted i
wasn't using those so that could be the
thing
another souls game sorry yeah i'm sorry
too hey your stream can you explain why
you pick vagabond and what you're trying
to build i chose vagabond because i'm
going to do a guts build there's a
weapon i'm going to find and show you
guys where it is that's basically the
guts weapon
and i'm going to be doing that so that's
why i chose vagabond uh i'm going to
show you where it is because it's like
it's not hidden but like you have to
there's the game is so big that's hard
to find specific weapons
all right so this is uh if you're a
source rebuild you want to go here she's
going to be able to sell you a bunch of
sorceries as a revived abuse she was
kicked out of real lucaria the academy
of rayo lacaria so she's a sorceress
from there for studying bad things which
actually you can see here one of them
says it basically
uh let's see sorcery olympianus
conspectus which attracts sorcerers from
celia
grant is sorcerers
i'm gonna try to find the one that says
like why she was kicked out basically
[Music]
not the one by the knights of cuckoo
basic uh
sorcery of academia lucario
what wait i thought she had one oh you
know what i guess that was from the
network test and they must have changed
what she sells
so i take it back
then oh you know what let's go fight a
dragon actually we're gonna fight a
dragon and then
and then after the dragon we're gonna go
ahead and i'm gonna go get that grey
sword i'm fighting the dragon right now
specifically
uh because
i want more levels uh just so i can
equip this sword so i think we're gonna
do the dragon maybe the tunnels and then
from there i'm gonna get that great
sword
why are people on elder ring live stream
complain that it's not a masterpiece
are people on live stream complain that
or oh oh our people like on the in the
comments
so oh masterpiece how okay so here's the
thing i love breath of the wild
uh
the one complaint i'd have with breath
of the wild is that the weapons don't
feel this is a common complaint right
that the weapons don't feel very
important when you get them
so the exploration sometimes we get a
weapons the exploration itself is the
gift and what's fun
but still the rewarding things you find
don't feel that rewarding and then the
shrines are all kind of like samey in a
way and while i enjoy the puzzles of
them and solving them and finding them
that would be my complaint
the thing with eldon ring is that
exploration always matters there's so
many interesting things that you're
gonna be finding everywhere tucked into
every nook and corner and there's so
many unique weapons that don't break or
anything like that they're just cool
unique weapons
so
uh the combat like i said is like souls
and it's really fun in that regard and
then there's massive legacy dungeons
that are like previous souls games and
multiple in every area like there's the
big legacy dungeon but there's other big
giant dungeons in every area that are
also really cool to explore
uh this is finger hunter europe he's
basically gonna tell us about the dragon
who's up ahead and not to fight him
which we're not gonna listen to we're
not listening to your advice buddy we
got dragons to fight
funny how some of the horizon viewers
call horizon more the same this is
basically dark souls 2.0
uh i guess in 2.0 i mean same thing with
bloodborne right i mean like it's the
same style of game but i don't think
that's a bad thing i really don't
if you like the style of game it's one
of those things where if it ain't broke
don't fix it it's like mario right
people aren't complaining that a new
mario games like mario you know it's
like
of course you're getting a similar
mechanic but that's not a bad thing if
it's done really well and they
add a lot of ton of new updates
the game has crazy new updates to the
gameplay like the horseback riding the
jumping ass elements the stealth
like totally new lauren's story to the
game that's not in previous souls type
of games
uh like a brand new porn story that's
interesting to discover
like so many bosses in this game it's
unbelievable how many bosses there are
on this game with totally different play
styles and way to fight them um any like
i said the horseback style bosses too
are totally new
it's just it really is just incredible
how much contents in this game and how
unique it all feels and how interesting
it all is to look for and discover
so like
look that's why people are saying this
game is great
i hope i'm explaining it well and doing
it justice all i can say is if you play
this game and start exploring the amount
of things you're going to discover and
how many oh my god cool moments you're
gonna have is off the wall
as long as you're okay with the style of
combat that's really the only thing i
can say for some people that might be
like hold them back
and like luckily for me i happen to
really
i love the style of souls combats i love
the way it makes me feel
uh i love how like weighted and grounded
it is
for me that's that's part of my
enjoyment to these games that might not
be for everybody else
but you know i'm acknowledging that
but it is for me and i think it's for a
lot of people and if you like souls
games at all this is going to be a game
you're going to love and you've never
played a game like this
i really i still recommend it just to
see if you like it because it it
genuinely is more accessible too with
spirit ashes
and the way that they've done co-op in
case you're having trouble or the fact
that mainly the fact that you can
explore and go where you want so if
something's giving you trouble you're
not you're not gonna be stuck against it
you can go try to find something else
so
anyways that's my spiel
uh it's just it is such a good game i
really really do recommend it
uh i'm happy to be a from software
shield right now this game is so good i
i want to reward game designers for
making great games and you can tell that
they put a lot of time and love into
this game
and it's just like
it's just so good i i don't know what
else to say where did he go oh damn it
so i guess it decided that he was in a
bad area so he's gonna reload somewhere
else as you can see but he still has the
amount of damage to him that i've dealt
so you can see like he's still injured
it's not like i lost my progress on it
so that's happened to me before
all right where are you going you're
gonna do that okay
nope okay all right we gotta get out of
here
notice how also this is another boss i'm
not targeting against as people were
complaining
well some people were complaining that
i'm not targeting
again
i do it on purpose i really think
sometimes their bosses who are better
handled by not targeting
and like i said this is this is one of
them
uh
you can
get him knocked down
i think his weak spots his head but you
don't have to hit his head to knock him
down it's just enough damage in a row i
think
uh
but i'm just playing cautiously right
now
i've kind of like i've bought enough of
these dragons in this game to have them
pretty well figured out
so
because there are multiple dragons this
ain't the only one let me tell you
so
they're all fairly similar but different
and they they have different abilities
but at least like
in some ways the way you approach them
is going to be kind of similar oh god
just like did i get too greedy did i get
too greedy great you're on a mountaintop
that's not good
sorry i'm not looking at the chat very
much i hope you understand why since i'm
fighting a giant dragon but i do try to
be that elderly needs a big battle right
now mode oh god no please
oh wait i know you're just you're just
uh okay i got it you're meaning right
now on uh what's his name
i know you're meaning on dr disrespect i
got it i get you i see what you're doing
now i appreciate the meme thank you
yeah
i actually don't know how halo's doing
right now in terms of stream numbers but
hopefully good
yeah i don't i don't get the like
needing to chase trends thing
i'm so glad that's part of why people
love
including myself insults and dark souls
so much
was at the time it wasn't tracy's
friends it kind of created its own trend
but it still does it the best
and even then it's not like there's like
a ton of ways right it's not like these
are just like constantly pumped out
there's definitely more souls like games
at this point but
usually they're not like triple a
studios trying to replicate it or
anything
looking for that uh
oh no one more how bad would that been
if i died there was that a flawless
victory my dudes
fight flawless victory
hey
let's throw out some mortal kombat terms
is david reviewer a game spot uh i'm not
a reviewer i i call myself more of an
entertainer i make videos for them
but i never do reviews and if i do
reviews i'm not the reviewer usually i'm
just like a voice over for them
so
that's me
uh but yeah i work at gamespot
why doesn't the dragon kick you when
you're near he does he's just slow he
tries to stomp on you
uh you use any magic i am not good job
from k70 thank you thank you somebody
cares this is perfect souls like skyrim
zelda it really that is the best way to
describe it
i know it was a meme back in the day to
be like oh it's like uh dark souls
i know that was a meme but it's really
fair to say that this game is the
uh
dark souls meets breath of the wild it
really is like a merger of the two
fatality hell yeah
uh does the horse have stamina this yes
the horse's stamina is tied to yours
all right we're gonna keep on leveling
up strength and endurance again for the
build i'm going for so i can get that
great sword
i'm going to here because the mines
these tunnels and caves are basically
how you're going to get your uh your
smithing stones
and uh
so i'm gonna be going through here to
get a bunch of smithing stones and also
and after that
also levels for killing the boss here
but after that i think it's time to go
get the gray sword i think i'll be at a
point where maybe i can hold it without
being in the ultra heavy build and also
hold it in the sense of like
you know
i can hold it and use it because you
have to get your strength pretty high is
this like skyrim in the sense that it's
a big open world yes otherwise i'd say
in no other way is it like skyrim
that's really the only feature i'd say
is similar
uh these guys you gotta do a decent
amount of damage to otherwise your store
is just going to bounce off of them
which you know what i'll go ahead and
show on one of them
so see how there's the smithing stone on
the wall
smithing stone is going to be how you
upgrade
okay i want to show against one of these
guys i just have to choose who no this
guy's fine i'll show you this guy
see how my store just like bounced
afterwards
uh that's where you got to be cautious
with these dudes
yeah nothing at all like zelda skyrim i
mean it's like zelda and skyrim in the
open world factory and more like breath
of the wild and the sense of discovery
that you have
uh it really is an okay comparison for
breath of the wild in my opinion
um but that's about it
so
yeah it's
it's so good guys it is so good
are dex builds i haven't done a true
decks build yet but there have been some
weapons i've found that look really cool
that are decks buildy
the game is so long that i basically
went with one build and that's kind of
what i've had to stick to
because of how big the game is
uh i mean look you can find a character
to respect your stats so you guys are
aware i think that's some important bit
of knowledge later in the game
uh much later in the game
but the resources for doing that are
limited and at this point i've leveled
up my
my sword so high
that i just haven't like had the time to
put into trying to master and level up a
new weapon like i have a couple weapons
that i've leveled up
uh i don't only have one
but they just haven't been dex weapons
that have leveled up
oh so notice how this smithing stone has
a one next to it i'm going to show you
guys that
uh it's going to be in here
the one just means that you can
reinforce armaments up to three you're
going to find sniffing stones two three
four etcetera uh gray gloss glove words
here
this is how you strengthen your ashes or
renowned ashes
uh if you wanna use those so again you
have to level those up
if you wanna use those they don't just
start super strong and their use is kind
of limited even then
it does help honestly i tried using the
spirit ashes there's a jellyfish one
that i got that really helped for some
bosses just by distracting them and
sometimes that's all you need
uh but for this playthrough or for my
last my main playthrough i decided that
i didn't want to use a single one and
that's just how i've been playing it
can vagabond do magic yes every single
build can do magic you just have to
level up and put stats into it
you can't choose between the source or
decks you could do like a a dual build
too
can you do a magic sword build sorry i
don't have the terms yes you can there
are magic stores in this game 100 there
are stores that i found that use faith
and you know a mix of dexterity or
whatever
and then there are stories that i found
that are just one
but yeah so you can 100 do those types
of builds
some dogs gonna run out at me right now
that's why i pulled out my shield
where is the enemy there we go i want to
take care of the doggy first
so hopefully i can get the dog
specifically
roll roll roll there we go okay we're
good
all right
nope
got it
uh looks like a ps4 game
uh i it was made for ps4 and ps5 so
that's probably why it looks like a ps4
game i think the size and scope of the
game though
is a little bigger in breath
but
look
i don't really care that much i think
the art direction is so good in this
game it doesn't matter i care a lot more
about art direction than graphics
personally and i really think that's the
way to look at things
art direction matters so much more than
bass graphics
if you have a good art direction it
doesn't matter i think and i really like
the art direction of these games
notice any frame drops i haven't
personally noticed any frame drops
there's a little bit of popping
sometimes for
like environmental details like a cart
or grass
that's about all i've noticed in terms
of that sort of thing but i haven't
noticed frame drops
we're gonna go here
uh can anyone answer my queue are there
still covenants i haven't found any
covenants
so no i don't think so
uh if i harm a boss an hour to say let's
say 20 run away and come back at hour 50
will the boss's house stay the same or
is it back to full it's back to full at
that point
so yeah that one will make it back to
full
unfortunately so
or fortunately depending on how you look
at it but yeah you can't just like
cheese a boss in that way it was
specifically with the dragon because i
was in the middle of the fight and it
reset where it's at
that that happened for me
but yeah in general you can't do that
um i mean then again i haven't really
tried i don't think but i i don't think
so
because when you basically when you rest
out of sight of grace it responds it
resets everything so i think if you
don't
rest at a sight of grace
i would guess at that point it doesn't
but since within those 25 hours you're
very likely to rest at a sight of grace
um
yeah i chose the wrong guy to attack
first by the way
so the guys with this
who are digging only aggro when you
attack them
that's why i chose the wrong guy to
attack first because i should have we
did i forgot there's another guy who'll
get aggro
okay uh
games performed better on ps5 fact
except for cyberpunk right
i actually really liked i'm one of the
few people who really enjoyed cyberpunk
i feel like but it did not perform well
on my ps5 it gave me so many bugs but
that was before the most recent pass so
who knows i hear the most recent catch
helps a lot
and i made a video about my experience
playing cyberpunk 4 game spot good
evening good luck and thank you for the
wonderful stream oh thank you so much
nikita i appreciate it and thanks for
hopping on i appreciate that too i hope
you guys are having a good time
uh like i said i'm gonna be going to get
a fun build thing coming up here real
quick
uh let me sorry i pulled away from the
chat okay so
i think at this point i've got all the
smithing stones here okay
again it's dark souls so you don't have
to use these elevators there's so many
hidden things to find guys in these
dungeons and there are illusory walls by
the way
most dungeons and places don't have them
but they are there and there are some
interesting secrets behind the ones that
they're some of them that there are not
all of them but some of them have some
really interesting secrets
so it is worth being a wall checking pro
my dudes
is worth it
okay so here's the thing you might have
noticed uh oh you know what we'll talk
about stakes america if and when i die
because i'm probably gonna die to this
boss since i only have two uh
tear chugs left by the way you drink
your own tears in this can you do a
wheeled build yes you can
uh you can do a build where you do wield
weapons
and they have unique attacks when you do
that or some of them do i don't know if
all of them do but i know some of them
do
all right let's see if i can take out
this guy or not
hey all right that's good
at least i'm doing up damage to him i
can do that
so the thing with this troll is that his
attacks actually some of them you want
to jump as opposed to rolling so we'll
see if he does that to me i'm sure he
will
or if i can kill him fast enough which
would be my preference
okay so this attack
okay there we go
no
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that second one there uh the second one
is the one that you want to jump over i
think so i made a mistake there i made
an oopsy
yeah so he's gonna pull it back up
sometimes and that's where if you jump
it helps that's how you dodge it
properly
i was doing so good
oh man i really thought i got that dodge
nope
not today it's going through control
okay maybe today
all right
good way to finish him off with this
roll
can we gank i think you can gank by
doing co-op
so or you can invade people too
all right roar medallion
something here this time around too let
me show the roar medallion real quick i
know i'm gonna quit because it's the
only one that i have
enhances roar and breath attacks which
i'm not using in ancient times the
giants were mortal enemies of the earth
tree
interesting eh their balloon roars
desolated nature triggered avalanches
and whipped up storms of flame so right
now we're being told to follow the earth
tree by becoming the elden lord by the
way but not everyone likes their tree eh
not everybody likes third tree okay
uh oh other thing i want to show you
guys is right now i only have one
talisman slot right here which actually
i'm not going to equip because it's
going to make me heavier and it doesn't
help me anyways but
you get more talisman slots as you play
by i think all of them have been by
defeating certain unique enemies also
when you finish some dungeons that are
more one-way there's a way to return to
an entrance in every dungeon like this
legacy dungeons all wrap around
but some of these like smaller dungeons
have this
okay so
that's good
let's go to the seaside runes maybe
we'll go to the ever jail again i'm just
trying to do some level up stuff thanks
for live streaming game looks here
regardless of consoles on i think it
will be
is there a story in this game yes there
is
it's again like from soft's typical
style it's a little more obscure uh as
they like to do with how they dish it
out
but it's there and you do have like the
basic like you're trying to go become
the elden lord by collecting great runes
from the shattered earth tree shards and
by doing so you can become the elden
lord they'll rule over everybody you
have a calling to go do it but then you
ask questions like who's calling you and
why
uh and then you start to find out
there's factions that don't like the
urgery and that idea and they think it's
wrong and like who do you believe and
who do you trust and what's right and
what's wrong so all that's going on in
this game
uh
how many difficulties are there in the
game zero but there's ways for you to
adjust how difficult it is for you
uh just by like
using spirit ashes which i'm not using
by summoning people and
oh poor lady
uh
spirit ashes you can summon people in to
help you out there's ways to adjust the
difficulty inherently and again it's an
rpg so you can level yourself up and you
so you can go around and try to level up
yourself you can level up your weapons
and equipment and stuff to try to make
it easier for yourself if you're having
trouble
such a clunky repetitive game this
should be dark souls dlc my ass get out
of here man
such trolley comments it's assuming
there's like that's like
i don't know as someone who likes game
design and cares about that stuff i just
that type of comment annoys me
just because i can tell how much work
and love went into this game and how
different it is
uh yeah get out of here man
okay
crap
nope i am bad on my timing here
one and two and three and attack
jump and attack
one and two and three
you see i have this guy down at this
point
oh
yeah so there's like some of these
enemies you do find again in other areas
uh there is a little bit of repetition
in that sense
but not all the time by the way these
jails are interesting so
ever goal
it's actually pronounced jail and they
are literally jails
so sometimes you'll find like
interesting like oh wait why was this
character in the jail
uh because it really is a jail they're
in oh by the way in this in the
everglades you can't summon the spirit
ashes so there are areas like bosses
like this that are specifically designed
to be more difficult and i don't think
you can co-op either in these so they do
do stuff to try to like
uh balance it out in a sense with these
ever jails like these are going to be
challenges
that you can't do
uh with that extra aid then again
you can level up and come back when
you're a higher level for these things
so there are some that i've gotten to
where i found the average jail later
where i was like way too high of a level
and then it kind of trivialized the
fight
uh but
you know it kind of depends on when you
choose to tackle this stuff so
no i'm just going to play safe and run
away and heal
lay
damage bill penny perry you can parry
i'm not the best at it yet in this game
because i haven't figured out all the
timing
yeah we need people we need p perry king
p to come peep perry but yes you can
perry in the game in fact i will show
you right now perry
i'm more of a two-hand guy but here we
go bam perry okay and you get the
riposte afterwards if you pull it off
i reminds me of artorias oh that guy
yeah he does look a little like artorias
okay where do i want to go oh you know
what there's another dungeon i should
probably just go to real quick and knock
out just because like it's right there
uh and i'm gonna go try to get the great
sword
may i have a word
all right
let me point the screen
actually how is the map side insanely
big it is gigantic and there are so many
things to find in it
i'm assuming there are blood spells etc
in the game there are yes what covers
the potency for that i didn't see a lux
stat
i think arcane does for blood but i or
you know what
okay so there's blood in terms of like
bleed in terms of getting hurt and i
think arcane helps with that as well as
just general magic stuff
um but there's also blood spells you can
use on enemies
and i think that's just intelligence or
faith and the witch rena
i'd heard tell of a tarnished hurtling
about to talk remember from the trailer
and upon looking into the matter
the talk i surmise is of
i'm gonna do it actually i'm gonna do it
in just a moment i am going to show you
that that's what i'm doing this build
okay so anyway she's gonna be the one
who gives you uh the spirit calling bell
this is how you use your spirit ashes
and she gives you some spirit ashes
uh she's an interesting character too i
don't fully know everything about her
yet there's a lot going on with her
there's a lot going on with her she's
actually pretty important and
interesting uh okay let me level up my
strength again and just keep on pumping
into that because i want to make sure i
can use the grade sword i'm gonna fight
one more boss that's gonna be quick and
then we're going to go get the great
sword and i'm going to show you guys
where it's at so if you don't mind
holding on for a moment
i'm going to show you that stuff she
looks like melania in the sense of she's
got the the tattoo
otherwise i don't think she's a finger
maiden like melano
or she has any relation to the finger
maiden so it's interesting but i don't
know exactly what the tattoo is or what
it means
so
i haven't figured that out yet
all right so see this is another cave
that's actually not any way to indicate
it on the map so see this map and
everything i've explored so far and done
this is a tiny fragment and all this
doesn't even show you how large the
world is just by zooming out like that
that still doesn't show you hey dave
platform preference performance i'm on
playstation five i think it's performing
well
uh this drama
so there you go
empty open world three out of ten game
yeah yes so empty so empty
uh okay oh also i mentioned the torches
are important in one of my videos this
is what it looks like without a torch
this is what it looks like with the
torch
you can see that you really do want a
torch
so yeah keep that in mind that you're
gonna want a torch
this dungeon has a lot of wolves in it
wolf's wolves in it um
i think they're all sleeping because
it's nighttime
but we're gonna come deal with them
after i fight the boss
because the boss is right here so notice
how the other dungeons i was in
somewhere bigger somewhere smaller this
one is tiny
some of them are big though
this guy now should be a pretty trivial
boss fight as i was mentioning
the more you level up the more you
triple you should realize some things
this guy was like right at the beginning
though so it was supposed to be like a
very early on boss fight i think this is
the only super trickler one here though
also i think you can backstab him oh wow
uh the reason he's trivialized mainly
though is because i'm using the grey
sword so notice how i'm stunning him
other swords wouldn't be doing that to
him
so that's partially just use the weapon
i'm using honestly
okay let's see if i can get the backstab
backstab all right
i know i'm making the i hope i'm not
making the game look too easy save force
one more time please torch
i don't even care all right
oh he only gave me one thousand
oh well okay i mean he like i say it's
supposed to be one of the beginning ones
that's the other way that they kind of
like the amount of experience points you
get is pretty well balanced here where
like
you know going back to someone who's
like when you over level and such
you're not going to get much for them
like that's not going to give me a level
up
but hey guys let's go get the great
sword let's go become guts shall we
guts time
all right
wait i remember that voice weren't you a
dslr guy yes i am four hours of 40
minutes ago jonas what's up yeah uh dave
controls my personal youtube channel
and yeah i've done
tons and tons of dark souls lore
all that oh you know what since this is
here i'm gonna get it now sorry then i'm
gonna do the great story just because
last time it wasn't there so that was
kind of frustrating
i mean disappeared on me
so
i'm guessing it was just like went out
of range or something for where it was
supposed to be
and that's what happened
[Music]
all right yeah and this camp should be
pretty easy now at this point just
because i've leveled up my strength
enough
yeah so the guys who blow the horns
though like you really want to take them
out first if you're in a difficult area
because that's what's gonna like
basically get everybody to go to you
you can see what happened right there
was that
if you get hit enough you'll get knocked
off your horse and while you are you're
very staggered
you're very very staggered and there's
some bosses and enemies who will very
much take advantage of that so
uh beware of that
uh we need more guts to be guts a
is true
how is he playing the game i thought it
releases the apm i have a review copy
so that is how i'm playing it
but yeah if you don't want spoilers i'd
say definitely don't watch i honestly
like i don't i don't want to spoil stuff
for people who don't want it
so why laura's presented is the way lord
is presented the same way
yes
it is presented the same way as dark
souls although it's a little more okay
it's presented in the same way to an
extent but there is more that you'll
find out
oh i thought he was just sad i guess he
stopped i thought he like did that after
you killed this guy
uh it's presented in the same way
but
that's not to say that like it's not
still explained more because there's a
lot more there's more npcs and they're a
little more talkative in this game about
what's going on
so you'll
you'll still get dialogue but it's also
fragmented in the way of dark souls and
there's a lot there that's hidden for
you to discover by like
really looking into what npcs say
really reading uh into item descriptions
and even those npcs say things and
they're more talkative a lot of it's
still very cryptic like they'll say
stuff like oh
i don't believe this thing and this
character blah blah blah but you're like
i don't know who this character is i
don't know who you're referencing i
don't know what they want and i don't
know why you think this thing's bad
you kind of have to like really figure
that out which i like personally but i
know it's not everyone's jam
uh
i accidentally like triggered uh i was
gonna
[ __ ]
oh no
this one the easier version of the
giants too
all right
hey
now we can go get what's in here
now we can see it
uh this was a totally different weapon
in the network test than what we're
gonna find here
the game is being rolled out from east
to west i guess it's a time zone thing
all right got ourselves a great axe
uh you know i'm gonna go get my estus
flasks back and we're gonna go get our
great sword now
this will be game of the year yes
yes it will be i have no doubt in my
mind i mean already i've no doubt
there's so many games coming out that i
want
like kirby i'm a big kirby fan i
absolutely love advanced wars so i'm
excited to see the re-release of that
uh there's another game coming out next
month i was super excited about too
and then like horizon was released this
month like it's been insane how many
games they've come out that have been
like
are supposed to be so good or are so
good
and still like this game is just
magnificent like like i said there's no
way that something's gonna be out this
game i can't see it happening
okay so
uh like our working review for game spot
by tam is a 10 out of 10.
uh and i can't see him i'm further than
him in the game and i can't see it him
changing his mind at all after game
further okay so what we're going to do
right now is we're going to go to caled
or khalid i'm not sure how to pronounce
it i'm going to go with caleb for now
uh we're going to caleb
uh that's going to be how we get our
next one let me just go find the map
fragment first real quick
to help me out
because i don't have the world's so big
i know the general direction i know that
is to the east
but i don't know uh
remember the exact like route to get
there
oh yeah there's also seafood that's
right
so
yeah so much man
all right we are now in mistwood
this was pretty sick
uh there's actually some there's you
basically find guts here
uh which i'll go see i i haven't found
him in my own game in a sense so like i
found him but not through the mist would
way
oh [ __ ]
that bear i think is mad at you when you
do that
all right we're now engraved east
yo so we're going over here to caled
uh i want to see if i find guts though
i know never mind
there's an area here by the way i don't
want to show you guys because i think
it's way too big of a spoiler uh i'm not
so i'm going to skip that i don't want
to spoil that for anybody game informer
already and spoiled it which i'm pissed
at them about because
uh man i want to talk about other alice
but just like i was watching it
i watched the live stream for work
basically about like all the things
because they got to play the game before
everyone else
so i watched their q a for the sake of
making videos
and some of the stuff they spoiled i was
like come on how could how dare you how
dare you
uh especially when i got to it i was not
i wasn't happy with that
okay so
the church of america here something
important here that i'm going to show
you guys
first of all this is where the flask of
wondrous physic is
so that's going to be our
third flask oh how do i sell that
equipment that's our third flask option
uh
and that one we're going to mix to be
our own also we find the sacred tier
here sacred tier is going to be how you
upgrade how much your
flasks heal you for
oh yeah star feel comes out too doesn't
it man it's like insane insane how much
is coming out
okay so if i go to flask i can increase
the amount that my flasks replenish now
thanks to the sacred tier i think
there's 10 of them in the game but i
could be wrong
uh now we're gonna mix our wondrous
physique
right now i only have one crimson
crystal tier which restores half of
total hp but we're going to find more
and we're going to be able to really
customize it you can only use it once
though no matter how you customize it
note itself don't read the gi article if
i don't want spoilers yeah like
i don't know if they wrote in the
article i know in the qa he mentioned
the thing and i was like dude especially
when i found the area i was like man
that was one thing you should not have
spoiled for people
uh
and also apparently like even like
bandai namco when he found aries like
you need to leave
and not look further into it so like
i will go full weave and samurai i'm
sure that's a really cool build for
samurai
halo was game of the year 2021 i don't
know man if it's up against because with
the way it released because it released
technically after for at least like the
game awards and such
after
uh didn't it
so if it's up against elder ring ain't
happening man i'm sorry
what do you think the best class to
start for the game runner up with
horizon five psychonauts two psychonauts
two in my opinion should have been a
game of the year last year
uh in my personal opinion that was the
best game of the year
uh okay so sorry the question was
what do you think the best starting
class for the game is
i'm gonna go with vagabond if you're new
otherwise it's whatever you really feel
because you can level up as you want and
change things up
invaded by anastasia get out of here
anastasia i'm gonna go ahead and do this
okay i'm at a cookbook and what's the
other thing
so there are npc invasions clearly as
you can see here
you can't use your horse when you're
getting baited by the way that's why i
got off my horse as soon as you get
invaded you have to get off your horse
um
yeah i really want to
i really really want to
get to this great store so that's why
i'm dealing with her so i can get back
on my horse
uh okay
oh yeah there's like other ones npc
invaders earlier on because technically
this area is a little bit later than i'm
going to right now and kayla's
especially is a very late area for the
game
you do not want to be in kayla early
trust me
except for getting this great sword
we got to get our weapon but other than
that you don't want to be in galen so
yeah
okay so for calling finger remedy and
this
sacred scorpion charm i don't remember
what that does let's see if that's any
better oh yeah there's also this boost
fire damage negation
uh okay it raises holy attack power but
lowers damage negation i'm just gonna
equip
wait i'm not gonna equip this because
again
my sword man my sword
do invasions happen often can you
disable them
you
oh
because i'm in a new area essentially
melano's gonna uh ask me if i want to go
to the roundtable hold on where's i mean
which is our games
gathering so i'll i'll just do it right
now real quick just so i get the uh well
because you have to a
but also just
i'm going to warp back to here so it's a
good thing i got that shrine of grace
i keep on calling the shrine of amano's
by accident clearly dark souls 2 is
still in my brain somehow
this guy's pretty good from jacob thank
you i appreciate that man
okay
this guy
is an interesting npc i'm just going to
say that i'm just going to say that i
don't want something else
it's called the table of lost grace
though they call it the roundtable hold
but table lost grace so that's kind of
interesting think about that
uh
think about that from a lower
perspective all right let's go to the
smoldering church again
how the [ __ ] do you get it early um
because it's a review copy so you guys
are aware oh i also wanted to level up
because i think i can level up again so
let's put another one into strength we
are building up our strength man we are
building this up
hopefully i don't need more decks for
this weapon because i can't remember
exactly what the weapon stats were that
you need for it but i've been saving my
uh i've been saving my smithing stones
for this weapon too so
okay let's see
i think this is the way
this is the way yeah
and yeah sorry if i'm missing any
questions or anything by the way i'm
trying to glance down at the chat as
often as i can
uh you don't get invaded very often by
the way if i've been playing offline
just so you guys are aware
because i have an update in my
playstation account and i need to pay
for another year and you can't play
normal online without doing that
uh just so you guys know as well
uh for a ps5 but the other reason why
and by the way we are now in caled oh
i'm going to stretch it to daytime so
you can see what kayla really looks like
uh you can pass time and like i said
there are things that only happen at
night time by the way there are bosses
that only appear i don't know if that's
the case with daytime but boss wise some
only appear during the daytime here you
go caleb
yeah it's basically a hellscape so
uh okay anyways
we're gonna keep on going
i am playing solo and you get invaded by
npcs i
think i guess people have been telling
me there's no invasions online solo but
i don't know if that's true
i really don't i feel like i found
something that lets you invade people
later in the game but like way later in
the game
so i think it's like a much later thing
that you get but you still can't get it
okay
we're gonna avoid that for now so see
that
this thing right here this thing has got
my
item i'm probably gonna die for going
for it but i'm getting it i'm getting
the great sword we got the great sword
all right let's get the hell out of here
these guys are no they're gonna mess me
up so we got it we got it we're leaving
and right now i can't warp by the way
i'm trying to access the menu but i
can't because when enemies are trying to
fight you you can't warp
so
resting at the side of grace will
re-activate them basically it'll like
reset things so then you can warp
any monger anime references in this 100
berserk is referenced in this uh there's
a character who's basically straight up
guts so
um
i want his set so bad
so bad
all right let's go ahead and see what
the stat requirements are for it 31 ah
okay i think i have 26. uh so i should
be able to at least wield it
where's my stats i have 25
two-handed i'm pretty sure
wait hold on what does it say you unable
to use this item effectively present
attributes unless wielded with both
hands so we're going to dual wield it
then and we're gonna level up and we're
gonna use this thing
uh right now i'm on a heavy load so
let's take off some let's take out some
items medium load there we go
i'm going to run around naked my guys
just so i can use this weapon
oh wait [ __ ] we're gonna get rid of
the shield
that should help and hopefully i can put
on like something okay let's at least
put on pants a
all right we're gonna wear some pants
yes
yes we got it okay
you see it is super super slow and heavy
but it is amazing
how far do enemies chase you uh they
chase you for a while but not like you
can definitely get away though
all right
uh let's go to gate front where am i
where should i go next let's see i'm
trying to find another dungeon just so i
can get some
ruins just so i can level up my grey
sword and then use it for a boss
can you lure creatures to other
creatures to fight each other some
creatures do fight each other
some do but a lot of them don't so oh i
wonder if i can even use this
horseback
or if it's gonna be like not usable
horseback
i don't know if that damage was good or
bad to be honest
i think it was okay
i don't know
stop it with your horn do not use that
oh god
oh god
yeah it's very very slow but i still i
think it might be going slower than
normal because of how
now it's going normal okay i guess i
guess i'm wrong
yeah like honestly this weapon isn't
very good horseback the other one's way
better for horseback
but it's so cool so cool
okay
uh griffith yeah
what's the main difference between
vagabond and confessor if even i can do
magic with those two character
characters you can do magic with every
character
here is where you find golden seeds
uh you find them by these things right
there oh and i recommend going to south
limb grave first by the way
before you head to storm hill ah there's
a much better choice
if you're new
much much better choice i'm probably
gonna make a starting guide for people
too i'm gonna work on
all right this woman right here
just so you know there are npcs whose
quest lines advance once you beat legacy
dungeon bosses she is one of them she is
very important and you probably want to
make sure you progress your quest line
properly before anything else
so uh
she's also going to give us a spirit
ashes that's nice of her for the
jellyfish
it's scary
she's basically talking about how uh
she's supposed to go get grafted
and i guess people are getting grafted
at storm hill castle and they're going
to get grafted
wait how many uh actually let me see
something how many of these do i have
maybe i can go level up actually
ashes church of ella
what's the best class to start as for
runeblade spell sword build
uh i'd say either the one that gives you
intelligence or one that gives you
dexterity and strength like just so you
have that basis
but
again you can level up however you want
at that point i don't know anything
about this does it have villages
not really your roundtable holds
basically gonna be where npcs hang out
which is up here or table lost grace
roundtable hold
all right let's try to level up my
weapon
i need 1 000 okay yeah that's what i
thought with this one yeah the great
sword like it's also expensive to level
up it really is a later game weapon
no let's let's just hm
where do i want to go i'm trying to
decide if i should go ahead and just go
for it with margaret
and say yolo but he's probably gonna
really mess me up you know i'm gonna go
down here actually first
and then we're going to go there
then we're going to go market it up
oh look you unlock staying sideways hell
yeah
no you can be alluring with the great
sword
yes
you know it hold on let's see let's
build actually when you use a gesture
you put away your weapon unfortunately
no i want my weapon out
oh yeah oh yeah
how is that little duke carrying that
big old sword because i'm guts man
actually you could change your looks and
you ca i could change my looks again so
he looks a little more like guts which i
should have done
um i was just trying to roll through the
character creator and just use the basic
starting one
i'm reminded when bloodborne came out
just an unstoppable hype train as it
should be
as it very well should be
yeah this game is fantastic so
that's why i say that
just because i want to chain bills later
in the run behold the allure yes
yes
why can't we talk about the technical
standpoint of the game
is this stable this framework does it
crash sometimes we can talk about it
uh here's the thing though i'm playing
on ps5 so i can't tell you for pc
i can tell you that i've had zero
crashes i played for about 75 to 80
hours on pc sorry ps5 with zero crashes
the only issue i have is sometimes
there's slight popping but that's it and
when i say pop in i mean like foliage
and things like that not enemies
look it's bach bach what happened to you
you must read this leave this place or
crush you to a pulp like me
i think he says they rush you too oh
they'll rush in and beat you to a pulp
so he kind of gives you a bit of a hint
about how the bosses are gonna work
it doesn't seem like you've gotten
accustomed using jumping attacks stuck
in dark souls mindset there actually are
some bosses i use it for
but i honestly haven't found that it
helps me that much
unless you're like on a cliff
if you're on a cliff then i'll use it
but like otherwise i usually don't
yeah
oh yeah
but yeah i mean i just haven't found
them to be all that useful because they
also take longer
boom
great sword baby ultra great sword
yeah like literally it looks like guts
is sword right it just is straight up
guts his sword
like it looks like the dragon slayer
and i am all for that
oh god all right actually he's not doing
that much damage to me if i had a high
enough level
at this point because leveling up all
that strength did level up my defense
yeah i got to like bounce between
strength and endurance just for the sake
of uh
just for the sake of
being able to use some sort of uh deep
armor
because i don't like having a heavy
build so yeah
no no no no no
yeah also it uses up stamina pretty damn
fast with this weapon
oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay
yeah really the hard thing with this
fight is it's a gang fight so notice how
like there's these other guys trying to
fight me too
this is honestly one of the harder
beginning fights in my opinion
we're fighting in the dark not we're
fighting the dark oh yeah yeah i miss
berserk too man that was like a true
tragedy cantata
like honestly ultimate tragedy
i'm trying to take care of some of the
like little peons so they don't mess me
up too much i'll try to take care of
this dude
okay get out of here
demi human chief mommy you don't deserve
that title
you don't deserve it also i'm gonna
backstab you wait i missed it somehow
that sucks i think you can backstab them
bad timing on my part
oh god oh god i untargeted just to hit
that guy and it didn't work out for me
all right got him
get tailoring tools and sewing needles
so this is going to allow us to change
the appearance of some of our uh
some of our clothes
like it's pretty minor in how much you
can it's like basically just like
removing capes or adding them on or
stuff like that for some
things but that's about it
to my knowledge
i miss uh i already saw that down with
the chefs down with the chefs
did i say chefs instead of cheese i hope
so
all right let's go chat up bach
real fast
so remember that sewing needle i got but
we gotta cheer back up because we just
beat demi
human chiefs who uh you know tried to
murder him
hey bach oh
give him the sewing needle and he's like
oh me mom i love sewing now i'm gonna
want to live
too bad you can't block or counter with
swords
you can block with swords actually hold
on
what made you my mom and that's okay so
he's all happy he wants to live now
thank you you're welcome
so see like oh wait whoops that's that
but i see i'm blocking with the sword so
you can block with the sword it's just
not nearly as good as using a shield
can you still guard tackle with ultra
greatsword weapons in this game i think
so
hey dave why is your face cam so low oh
uh i'm
it's just because i don't really have a
stream set up so i'm sorry like i could
put it on another chair but like i just
don't have a stream set up so i'm sorry
about that
um
yeah my bad on it but i tried to put it
like as far in the corner as possible so
like at least it went into uh
you know at least it wouldn't like take
away from the game
so yeah is the gray sword good for early
gamer kind of class cannon
uh it's a little bit more glass cannon
early game especially because you notice
that i don't really even have the stats
to use it yet i have to two-hand it
um and i had to take off my armor and it
you really like leave yourself open when
you use it
so it's like it's not i wouldn't call it
a glass cannon in the sense of like
it doesn't make your defense any lower
except for like it's so heavy that i had
to take off good armor
as you can tell
but other and i have to two-hand it
right now otherwise i can't use it
effectively because it requires so much
strength
but i'm still making it viable right
so
i just have to keep on removing my uh or
going back to two-hand every time i come
up to an enemy so
it's kind of like on you if you feel
like it's viable or not but
i'd say honestly if you want to use a
heavy sword early game this is what i
was using was the lord
lord swarn's great sword
it's not nearly as heavy like right now
i'd be a light load from heavy load or
medium load sorry you can equip decent
armor and it's still pretty damn good
so that would be my recommendation for
early game i just thought this would be
like a fun unique thing to do because
everybody's streaming the game right now
and also i love berserk
and guts is a g
so
i just thought it'd be fun to like you
know do something totally different and
have a totally different build they're
probably not going to see anybody else
do because i happen to know where the
grey sword is and i happen to really
like berserk so i was trying to do
something different uh and get this
real men don't wear armor from numbers
uh numbers suck yeah that's true real
men don't use armor
that's the truth okay so the church of
dragon communion
that's how you're gonna use your dragon
hearts and you can buy a few different
um dragon spells essentially each one
requires one dragon heart
and there is another dragon communion
church you can fight with way more and
you can find way more dragons with me
way more dragon hearts so
that's that also there's a ash of war
down there somewhere but i'm not gonna
get it because uh i'm gonna go level up
my great sword and we're gonna go fight
margaret
you probably need tons of string you do
get string in the game i love to stay
but i'm going to on a detox until i can
play it myself no problem michael uh
thanks for hanging out while you did and
i understand man like seriously enjoy
the game on your own
enjoy the game for yourself
all right let's go ahead and level up
our
great sword and you know what else i'm
going to do actually because i've been
leveling up my strength
is we're going to equip an ash of war to
it and we're going to change the style
of build that this weapon is so if i go
to ashes of war
um basically
let's just do let's do sacred blade that
sounds fun oh i can't okay
oh it's only letting me do i can't do
heavy yet maybe i have to find something
to make it so i can do heavy
so when you choose a heavy affinity it
changes the scaling so it's a b strength
scaling and no deck scaling so that's
going to make it so slightly better for
my build
but uh anyways
i haven't found anything that's s
scaling yet but it might be special boss
weapons i haven't upgraded
i literally never played the dark souls
game so i'll probably go vagabond like
you suggested i think that's a good idea
honestly i say vagabond and
either the long sword or seriously the
lord swore in grey sword is probably
what you want to do
uh great fat boy i like your name me too
i'm very curious to see what seoul's
newcomers think about the rain yeah me
too i'm curious to see i think i'm gonna
go prisoner that'll be fun to see
oh wait i can upgrade my estus charges
again because i got a golden seed so i'm
going to go ahead and do that
uh and let's go to market let's have
some fun
you know let's uh let's go to stormville
castle
why not
something different right
okay so knows how says i need one golden
seat to increase the number of flask
uses that i have eventually that's going
to change and you're going to need more
but now i have seven uses or six uses
sorry
just because i started one for my
starting class
and i found
uh one now
so
yeah
i'm not gonna fight them because i just
don't care
uh this is gonna show you that you can
just kind of like skip enemies sometimes
if you know where you're going here's
another ash of war i'm doing like no
damage to this thing
all right maybe actually my because i'm
one handing it really is low damage
since i'm on the
since i'm on this
but yeah so you can find those things
around and they'll drop like ashes of
war other goodies if they're red they
give you more crimson charter flasks
recharges back
and if they're
uh there we go
yeah see how it's like red i wonder if i
i should look to see if there's a red x
on it when i'm going horseback
but uh anyways
anyways
uh blue one will give you more fp flash
recharges
this ultra great sword uh in a specific
location it is and i showed where it was
earlier in the game i i don't think
anybody drops it that i'm aware of
so
hey what's your youtube channel name on
future guys dude uh my youtube channel
name is dave control but i'm making
guides for gamespot so my guys are gonna
be on gamespot
um
there's already a tips for newcomers
guide that we posted today that i made
that's like some tips for you guys i
tried to be as spoiler free as possible
in it but there's some minor spoilers in
it
uh and i'm gonna try to make a
beginner's guide i'm hopefully gonna
write that today
uh that's gonna be my goal and then i'm
gonna be doing a
golden seed guide eventually and i'm
doing a sacred tear guide as well
they should name this game elven souls
yeah in a way
i do want to do like a how to fight make
a
guts build as well
oh god i do like no damage to him with
the
this weapon i wanted to see what i did i
just kind of ran into him and he's gonna
be a hard fight
i'm so slow i should honestly probably
be switching to the great sword other
sword
i don't realize my damage is gonna be so
crap
well let's see how many hits i can get
on in here hopefully at least two
okay
i think mark is a pretty difficult fight
honestly so we'll see how this goes i'm
not making any promises
jump at me please thank you
this beginning phase of the fight's
pretty easy but like he has a second
phase that i just
he wrecks me pretty much every time no
matter what with the second phase
so i i'm making no promises about how
well i'm gonna do on it
or how many attempts it might take me
my recommendation to with margaret is do
what i'm doing for this first phase keep
him far away the stuff he's going to
attack you with are a little bit harder
is this on uh this is a playstation 5
i'm playing on
also i have my stream settings kind of
low so i don't know how it looks on
stream by the way
um
i'm not i'm not sure about that
all right
now you should go into
mad at me mode yeah so check it out this
is the second phase of the fight this is
when it gets real
real real
like really really really legit
do they have guts hand cannon in this oh
i don't i haven't found it wait actually
oh my god i think there is a hand cannon
or some kind of cannon so maybe they do
dude that would be
oh my god i didn't think about that
[ __ ]
oh god oh god
instead of attacking him here
that's what's happening
let's use my wondrous physique because
it doesn't kill me for as much
one and two and hopefully does that
attack yesterday
now i can't hit him as much there he's
actually being kind of nice to me right
now to be honest
um
he definitely has like more difficult
stuff that he hasn't thrown out at me
one and nope actually let me get
attacked
ring the game where i say weird ass [ __ ]
oh
i got one in oh god oh god oh god
no no
okay
yeah
so uh that's kind of what i was
expecting well the combat feels great
yeah yeah and like really i love the
weight of the weapons
man i had four charges left too
that's my first boss death i think right
i've been pretty doing pretty good up
until this point
uh
i apologize
but yeah this guy like i said this guy's
tough i
i could go like run around and level up
more and make it so i'm using more of a
viable build because i didn't really do
that for myself yet
but even then this guy's tough uh i mean
like if you run south that's probably
the better idea
which i didn't do
so i like i'll put that out there too
like i really should have gone south
i was hoping see the fact that i can
only get i can't even get two attacks on
him without him
hitting me
this yeah this sword is probably not
good for him
uh with that one specific strike i
should say that
yeah i know i normally do more damage to
him
oh crap
he actually hit me with that
yeah i might actually need to run south
now i think about it
yeah you only lose your uh
rooms when you die it's ruins in this
game as opposed to just that's the name
of it in this game your souls are called
runes
yeah see how he has scorpion tail attack
normally with other builds i can like
get a bunch of attacks in and dodge
right away afterwards
but not this one maybe i'll have to
switch swords actually for him that
might be a better idea
well
if i die to him again i'm going to
switch swords
smarter with it
no
i was really hoping i could get that
attacked
no
damn it
the fact that i missed that sucks
all right well at least i can get this
attack and roll away
nope nope
oh god
i'm so not good at this phase of the
fight
at least this i know what to do it's
like he does that dodge twice
try to get the second attack in and hope
he doesn't yeah good i got lucky there
one and two and
why do i say things like that i don't
know
oh crap i know that they're actually i
can usually get the time with that that
was a little just
better to rest
in boston they fall off cliffs uh i had
that happen to me in the network test
with the knights cavalry guy
actually i haven't had it here
sounds like they changed the music of
the fight comparing it to network tests
okay i'm gonna be smarter
unless you guys don't want me to be
smarter but i want to roll through stuff
faster so i'm going to go south here
uh
that story is cartoonishly huge it's
guts man it's guts
well it doesn't show with an x so i
guess it's fine here but it's basically
so i can like get some more runes right
now
and i actually want to test something
with an npc thing with a quest line that
i've been wondering about so there's
that as well so this is kind of like a
good chance for me to test it
are the dual sense haptics good i
haven't noticed them to be honest
uh so maybe i just haven't been paying
attention
but i'm honestly not sure if they do
that i'll try to pay more attention
right now
maybe i'll let you pass if you say
something nice about a scorpion tail you
know what maybe maybe that's what i was
missing the whole time oh i forgot about
the sight of grace
wait there's a fast travel form from the
map yeah yeah so uh you want to fast
travel hey
oops
yeah you go to the map and you can fast
travel at any point from sights to grace
which is why they have stakes america in
the game
stakes and merit are essentially
checkpoints that you can't fast travel
to and you can't rest at but if you die
against the boss
you can like immediately uh warp there
yeah i don't i don't know if there is
any haptic actually but you know what
i'll try to feel for it now
i just haven't really been paying
attention honestly
i've been like so in the zone with the
game when i've been playing
that just hasn't been like a priority
for me
i think there's a stone sword key around
here
so i'm just gonna go get
[ __ ]
i think this is it yeah there we go okay
so you actually remember that how about
that
uh surprisingly convenient
uh
so glad i got the series x on launch day
waiting all the time makes it even more
expansive because you just lost over a
year of its life cycle
well
i feel like it's finally starting to get
worth it to buy the newer systems
although i'm not going to talk to her
for a reason i think i've done her quest
line where we talked to her and she
always gets killed
so i'm trying something new i'm trying
to see if i can like do request line a
different way
i plan on every souls game i'm still
ready for this dude
yes
yes that's all i gotta say is yes
anyways
i need some more levels man i need to be
able to use this sword properly
also the fact that i've only leveled up
plus one i'd like to get a little higher
up that would help with market too
sometimes i've noticed dips
uh i don't know if you're noticing dips
at least while you're watching because
of me
or uh because of the stream i don't know
if it's the game or the stream because
i'm not noticing anything
is it better take golden cedar stone
store key as a gift golden sea
definitely the golden sea
you're gonna find a lot of stone sword
keys uh basically but golden seas are
much more limited and they're much more
useful in the long run
so and you can also purchase stone store
keys golden seas are rare so get the
golden seed
i also mentioned that in my guide for
the beginner's tips
too
but like hopefully i'll make another
guide for people
all right math for the weeping peninsula
so oh my god that's right i can't open
the map because i'm in combat
i notice there's a blue door tombstone
on the left above the item menu what was
that uh you know what i don't know what
you're talking about so i will go to it
after i defeat this guy
stuttering oh sorry there's stuttering
it's the stream it's not the game
so
i'm sorry it might be my internet being
weird
so this big boy looks cool but he's not
nearly as intimidating as he looks and
this dungeon i'm going to is basically
like a giant almost legacy dungeon sized
dungeon i mean okay it's not as big as a
legacy dungeon but it's pretty huge
so it's just to show you that like
there are giant dungeons in this game
there aren't the legacy dungeons
preparing market is a great way to
defeat him lower the stream also a great
job you can parry market i didn't know
you could parry margaret
is it still stuttering really bad
i mean if it is i can see if i can do
something about it but let me know
anyone's better on ps5 over series x
does it do we know that
how's the horse kind of that it's fun
it's very different and once you get
used to it i have fun with it i actually
do enjoy it but it's definitely
different it feels good though once you
get used to it
all right so we are at uh castlemourne
oh here we go you can see the weeping
peninsula
all right so you can start to see how
big the map's getting and like there's
so much to explore in this area in every
one of these areas i haven't even
finished exploring the beginning area of
limgrave yet and i am rolling through
this game guys so like
um yeah the stream is fine okay thank
you i'm starting here okay
that's throwing bad bro you're good
thank you guys i appreciate it
all right i might get wrecked here just
because of the the build i'm using but
hey we'll see we'll see
i have no idea how it's gonna okay the
fact that it takes me two is to kill a
puppy isn't good
you know that's all right i'll roll with
it
that's what we do man we're guts we
gotta we gotta struggle
right
my fellow strugglers also i got another
golden seed i think i could probably use
it there's a smithing stone too
i want to point this out
uh okay
there you can see you guys lets you
upgrade to plus six so you start to get
more of those types of versions
i don't know what the blue thing you
were referring to was though
all right uh
you know what actually i'm gonna see
something with the lord sword sworns
gracer right now and see if it's just
temporarily a better choice just so i
can use my shield
for the pups
other than dogs i don't really care
about the shield
oh it takes them three bits okay
you can see how much faster it attacks
that's like the that's the thing about
the
oh it still takes them three hits even
two-handed
okay
you know what screw it
let's go back to the great sword
it's more fun anyways
uh that guy up there
he's like the leader of all these guys
and castle morgan has his own
interesting story that i'd like to do a
lore video on i think once i figure it
out fully
because it's like
that's own little like sad history
yeah a lot of these areas what's cool is
that they have like they're definitely
filled with their own war which is nice
like you can really feel it that they
they put that sense of care into areas
where everything feels like it's there
for a purpose and reason
and obviously like you're the pile of
dead bodies and the guy chanting up
there on top of it it doesn't like say
it there but just visually you can read
the storytelling and when you start to
talk to some of the npc's relations
areas like oh yeah oh yeah i get it
it looks like i have enough for another
upgrade for my sword but that's
hopefully not okay wrecked by these guys
now that they're going to swarm me
these guys are called demi humans by the
way
oh i thought i'd roll off
all right let's see how
much damage i did for the big boy oh
crap
maybe i almost missed my roll there do i
stutter him at all i do that's nice
you don't stutter him with other swords
so it takes a lot to stagger him
apparently
but hey that's where this this sword is
nice
and that you can stutter guys like this
normally you can't
kind of hill is sitting sideways just
saying
i'll go glance in a moment
so how about ukraine oh
man i don't want to talk about it like
it's not like not that you guys can't
like it's it's frustrating and sad and i
don't really know what to say about it
um
it's just a tough situation you know
kind of like trying to be do some
escapism here because it sucks it really
sucks
oh something cool about this areas
speaking of
getting away from speaking of things
that suck
oh i love i've had times where i knock
enemies and fling them away to their
death with this weapon where i don't
even kill them but something else does
all right so you can see that guy who's
burning at the stake by the way the
thing that he has on him means that he's
an urgery follower that's what that that
thing is
and then over here we have a very sad
pumpkin head
oh
poor sad pumpkin head
thanks for the answer i'm
not sure if i answered you
it looks better than ds3 but it's no ds
demon souls remake well yeah but i mean
the demon souls remake was made only for
next gen consoles and it was only
you know
it was only made
for that reason where the all the
developer did
was make the game look better so i mean
like what i'm realizing is you could
probably get him to fight these guys for
you actually
i bet that's the case
probably you're supposed to do that and
i should have done that
because like they're at war these guys
are at war with the demi humans and
you'll see that up further
so i bet that actually i could have
aggroed him and made him fight uh demi
humans for me
uh yeah man if you're going with story
plus shield you can parry margaret
should really help that fight oh my god
i had no idea
all right i'm gonna try when i go back
to market because i did not know that
that's really cool thank you for that
info
mr mm or sorry
uh ali
ghidarzi or ali i'm sorry i'm not sure
which if it's ali or ali
are there any controller speaker sounds
like demon souls or star dark souls on
ps5 or demon souls
not that i've noticed no and i haven't
noticed like haptic feedback yet like i
know demon souls had that haptic
feedback with the uh the arrow i haven't
noticed that
um so i don't think there is happy
feedback like that
all right here we got another great
sword that i'm not going to use because
i got my super one
claymore looks more like a normal uh
great sword you know
that's a realistic one but i got my
dragon slayer and we're gonna use my
dragon slayer because it is awesome
yeah so see that these guys are at war
although hey you get souls or souls you
get runes no matter who dies so that's
nice getting runes for their desk thank
you
got sword hell yeah
roaring game do you learn more about
areas npcs haliburt's notes
all of the above
so npcs will talk about areas uh yeah
see like they fight me too these guys so
like
everyone's mean to me man
i'm not on anybody's side i just come in
and kill them all
with my greatsword
what how did this guy not die
oh he is i don't know how i missed them
that's shocking
speaking of which i'm getting low on my
estus jugs i keep on messes jugs it's
really teardrops we're chugging our own
tears in this game
so that's
i hope there's more ultra great stories
in this game there are i i've found more
this is the basic one but i have found
more so
there are more
let's get that nice backstab with it
wire torch
i don't remember how it's different i
don't think i can whip it actually oh i
can
does more damage is it heavier yeah it
is heavier so we're not going to equip
it because right now we got to worry
about that
actually it says heavier than a normal
torch but the heated filament boosts
fire damage dealt oh yeah so i should
show this off with the torch
you can do this wait
why is he not doing it
hold on
maybe i was using the steel wire torsion
i didn't realize
that oh i have been using the steel wire
torch in my game okay
well that's interesting i didn't i
didn't realize that hey dave how's the
element ringing from will crosby dude is
going fantastic how are you doing by the
way will
uh how you been
15 frames yikes what what are you
talking about
what starting class are you i start with
vagabond
but i'm telling you guys the starting
class doesn't matter very much unless
you want to go for a very unique build
right away which is what i did
it really does not matter very much
um
i promise i promise you guys that you
know what i don't know if i've been in
there oh god oh god
wow this is just a basic enemy that is
so dumb of me
yeah that's what i get for not looking
for ambushes right away
and also for trying to heal when he was
right there
great great great that's not good
so this is that ladder that we saw
earlier by the way that's right there
that i
i could have climbed up that i didn't uh
this is the area that i'm actually
worried about and why i was worried
about my estus jugs
because we got these flying guys now
oh one of them just fell off and died so
i guess at least that happened one of
them's taken care of
care of
crap yeah just because they can kind of
difficult to knock down
once you do they're good okay i guess i
got good with that area
get good i got good
hey look another fight going on down
there i don't know that oh they fell off
they're fighting over there that's why
i would like to go to this section i
just want to not
there's a there's a checkpoint right
there by the way
but
wait no wait yeah so like see right
there there's another side of grace
all right let's do it i want to find out
about the lore man i want to do the lore
stuff
so hopefully i don't get wrecked for
doing this
helping out my human bros
are they only ones fighting right now
everybody else fell off okay i guess
maybe i can afford to do this
got it captain bull thank you great
sword for being amazing
all right
oh crap there's this guy too oh wait
he's still alive all right
looks so dumb guys holding a sword twice
his sides
uh that's because i specifically went
for it this isn't a normal weapon
uh it's just an option in the game
and i shouldn't even be using it right
now
it's just berserk man uh there's a face
i know i'm edgar warden this guy you can
see how things
they gave me good service also i thought
foul creatures are saying sorry to
disable whatever so see he's telling us
some more about castlemore and i'm
afraid take this
by way of apology
now then away with you you no reason to
risk your
okay so you can find his daughter
and his daughter always ends up dying
for me and then he disappears and i'm
trying to figure out how to make that
not happen so i was thinking maybe if i
talk to him first as opposed to his
daughter first
uh why is everyone reviewing this game
on ps5 and not ps4 getting cyberpunk
vibes
honestly i just played i got that's just
what i wanted to play it on and i have a
ps5
uh they gave me a ps5 code because i i
think because i asked for it
uh and i'm just telling you that like
i don't know how the ps4 acts i have no
idea i'm just telling you that there are
zero issues on the ps5
none
um
and you know it's not like pc where they
could patch something i i mean okay i
guess they could patch something but
it's not like i have different specs or
anything like that all i can say is it
works great on a ps5 ps4 i guess we'll
find out
hopefully but i can't say anything
all right upgrading strength again we
gotta keep on getting that up so i can
use this weapon properly
okay
and then we gotta raise up our endurance
so i can use some armor you can see it's
starting to go slower and slower for me
getting these uh upgrades
okay i could drop down there to that
spot but there's actually a secret thing
here so you're going to want to drop
here instead
so we can get a stone sword key you see
now i've already found three
uh if not more let's see how many i
found actually
so i found three and you start with two
if you choose as the starting gift but
again
you're gonna be able to find a lot of
them whereas golden seas are much more
rare so get those golden seats
i do not want to get ambushed by you
oh here's another guy who talks by the
way he laments about
being noble and how like he was taken
prisoner by the demi humans essentially
and these demi humans were supposed to
help hold the port by the way
so that's the lore of this areas
essentially these guys were originally
sent in to help
from other enemies
during the shattering i'm guessing
uh and
they have not been holding up their
bargain and they ended up killing all
the humans and they're at war and
they've been killing everybody and
murdering everyone and taking over the
fort so
it was not good
so
yeah like these are all things that you
piece together you get a little bit
trumpet from the guy i was just talking
to
um but yeah yeah yeah
no fall damage there is fall damage but
you have a little more space for it in
this game because you can jump but
there's fall damage it's just high
enough and then you die straight up die
from certain heights
but yes there is fall damage uh it just
has to be a little higher
it's only good for pc for other ring or
not yet i honestly don't know i've been
playing on ps5 and i've been playing
offline
so i don't know
you have to have insane strength to use
huge swords yeah i mean like
yes
so as you can see with this huge sword
i've only been upgrading strength i now
have this 26 on the right side compared
to all my other stats which are in the
tens if not nine and seven
and i still if you look at this
i can't wield it properly if i go
one-handed
hold on you can see that there's an x
next to it on the left because i'm not
wielding it properly so i can't i don't
hurt enemies at all if i'm using it
one-handed
and that's the same with other great
swords too
i mean he does a backwards role as if
the game wouldn't prevent you from doing
that i mean guys at the at the end of
the day it's a video game right
you know i've been
obviously like
they're gonna have like a little bit of
stuff that's more gamey to make it a
game
i mean like look i just swung through
the wall essentially so like
every game is going to have a little bit
of that
it's just like depends on how well it's
balanced and if you like the way it
feels and like i personally like the way
they do the weightiness of these games i
think it feels good
like combat feels to me a lot more
realistic in these games even when i'm
using swords like this
uh and by the way i would die if i just
dropped straight down here um
compared to a lot of other games
because of like the weight of the weapon
that you feel and that's really what i
enjoy a lot about these souls games
and souls like games
is that weight of the weapons
i like that you can really feel it
as you swing it
i mean sometimes walls do block you as
it just did
oh god
the rats man the rats
and actually i think i'm by another side
of grace anyways
all right we gotta take care of this guy
dave this game is so unrealistic i know
man i know will i know
oh there we go another new weapon a whip
so there you have another type of weapon
you can use there's there's lots and
lots and lots
i want to see something on real estate
horizon west
turns out there's no dragons or trolls
in real life either unplayable i know
right
i know man oh my god there's dragons and
trolls too what the hell i wanted a real
one-on-one life simulator man
we're gonna skip this part because right
there we got a big boy boss my man we
got a big boy boss
all right
rip van winkler never said anything
about realism law
bro you're crazy you're rising another
level best visuals i've seen it's
probably i think i haven't played if i'm
sure it's really good
i play the original a bunch
leonine misbegotten
we're going to stun lock into submission
except right there
but yeah i recommend you go to this spot
first before market honestly uh you can
tell this guy's much easier and it's
gonna get you some levels if you need it
gonna get you a little more used to the
game
and he's about to kill me too hahaha i
did heal once i was being a little too
aggressive
the guy don't pay attention to youtube
chat you talking about me
i'm i'm reading uh all the chats musashi
so like basically i have the chat up
in um
i have the chat up on like a program
where i'm just seeing both at once so i
i'm just reading what i see
uh okay so here's a twitch chat one i
guess it does show me use more jump
attacks
okay i'll try to when i get a chance i
there are some bosses i use it against
like when i get to godric which i think
i'm going to be able to do in this run
uh when i get to godric you'll see me
using some more jump attacks you know
i'll use one right now how about that
see like it's just not worth it to me
man that's why i don't do it that often
i need to roll and i use up all of my
crap
that's just what i get
i accidentally stopped you handing my
weapon
i don't have time to look okay i started
crouching by accident that happens
sometimes
for me
here we go
oh
yeah sometimes he does power through
things
all right
there we go i was just trying to get
that stagger i think do it
uh i am playing a vagabond but i've
leveled up so much at this point that
there's not really much you can do look
you were asking about great swords my
guys
game scott guy if you actually see my
chat i'm just effing around while don't
take me seriously from repair winkler
okay
i do man i do see it
i'm reading it okay so
brand new one grafted blade gray sword
uh you can see this one straight
requirement is 40 and the dex
requirement is 14 whereas the one i'm
using is a 31 strength requirement
i can't even use this item at all
although this probably uses my decks but
it is swords grafted onto swords for
this blade which is wild
so there you go there's another giant
great sword as i was saying there's more
that you can get
i'm so tempted to play alton ring like
guts yo that's what i'm trying to do man
make the guts play throughs
is this uh version pc one this is p
version is ps5
so you guys know
all right let's see
oh my god wait it's not even raising up
my strength oh well
at least it raises up my
man i really need to level up my weapon
more
okay so sorry let me go back to chat
okay
i wanna see if anything happens now with
this guy so i'm gonna run to him real
quick
the iron throne sword it is the iron
throne sword
it absolutely is
i didn't even think about that before
but you're right
man i really want to beat margaret but
i feel like i need to level up my great
sword a little bit
i mean there's like so many dungeons i
could go to right now like all of this
is dungeons everywhere in areas with
little bosses and such that i could go
to
also there's more upgrades i can find
that i guess i could go roll through and
get that'll help out like gold seeds and
sacred tiers and stuff like that and
then oh yeah i wanted to try the perry
strategy that you talked about too maybe
i'm gonna do that
get some sacred flasks parry strategy it
up
i'm just gonna run through this
oh you know what i wanted to check too
i'm gonna check this guy
i'm gonna see if i can aggro him against
all of these things
let's see if we can start a war
between pumpkin head and these guys
all right let's see it let's see it
hey there they are they're fighting
they're fighting pumpkin head i'm gonna
leave it up to you thank you man i
appreciate what you do for me
i love you right now he's mad at me what
just because i woke you up from your
depression i was trying to get you back
to fighting it's called inspiration
oh god
well there he goes you buy pumpkin head
i hardly knew ye
is this made by the people who made dark
souls yes it is
let's take this guy
nice
they really need to patch mafia
wait so pumpkin had to respawn uh only
that one so there's a boss version of
pumpkin head and he doesn't respawn
the one that you just saw me fight was
not the boss version
and that guy respawns so there's pumpkin
has just a normal enemy in the game
so the one that you saw before as a boss
was like he feels like a big boss then
and then you just kind of find him
starts to be like kind of a normal enemy
and there's a couple bosses like that in
the game
so he's not the only one like that who
you'll end up saying morphing what the
how did those guys get there okay okay
okay
and not realize that those guys were
gonna fly up to me i'm gonna let them
all fight each other how about that
because i really just want to go to this
nbc
i'll take out this guy though there's a
jump attack for you
this is unfair fight i'm gonna go ahead
and help my guy out
for that one reason alone
all right let's see if he has anything
new to say because i got the sword away
with you no reason that's it okay
i really wonder if there's something i'm
missing here
i can't warp away these of the fights
all right i gotta
kill some dudes so i can uh
who's winning this fight
i guess you know what i'll do next is
upgrading my greatsword to plus two like
no no i'm gonna keep on exploring
keep on going for the level ups
look a little quality like an old mmo oh
my god dude just come on
i like how people just don't care about
a game being good anymore sometimes it's
like
you know game's incredible oh my god it
doesn't have the best graphics in the
world
even though they still look fantastic
it's like insane to me
all right
let's see
we're gonna go here
sorry
okay
now let's do it let's get this choppier
than i thought it would what system is
he playing i'm playing on ps5 and i
don't know what you're talking about
with chomp it might just be my stream
wait a second i didn't mean to go here
now well whatever now i'm here
i guess i'm here now that's okay
i really don't want to ruin how to do
this puzzle though so i'm going to
kind of peace out i think
graphics won't be amazing until ps7
how big is this map actually i tried
google picture and seems nobody has
exploited it
i have it pretty much fully explored i
think like there's only one map segment
that i'm missing but i haven't uploaded
a picture of it because it's not a it's
not allowed
but to answer your question the map is
gigantic
it is huge
uh and there's so much to discover in it
i'm uh
i'm about 75
hours into the game and you can see how
fast i'm rolling through this because
i'm good at these games
at least
um
i mean obviously i'm rolling through a
faster now because i know where to go
but the point is like
i still haven't even come close to
exploring everything
i've explored a lot and i'm at the final
area but there's a lot of stuff i've
missed
a hundred percent
okay i know there's a site of grace
around here that's what i was looking
for okay
how would you compare
invasion for god's sake all right i'm
playing offline sorry
i can't
and it's just not my i just this is not
me man i don't care about the invasions
or stuff like that in these games
uh how would you compare quality of
gameplay compared to other similar games
excellent
uh it is outstanding so yeah
it's essentially dark souls 4. you can
say that about bloodborne though i just
don't understand that it's like a
completely new world
open world which is completely different
in that way with all the exploration the
horse changes things a lot
uh just because it's similar to dark
souls doesn't make it the same thing
uh i don't know i just don't get that
comparison man
that is some berserk ass sword damn i
that's why i chose it i found it and i
was showing how to do a guts build
uh i'm on ps5 yes the other thing is i
don't have hdr turned on so that might
be affecting it i don't know
uh if that also affects it just a heads
up
uh okay
so
and this is gonna be fun switching
between my torch and everything
thing is i can't even one hand this
weapon yet
i think i still need like what three
more levels to be able to use this
weapon properly
ah come on
there we go
all right
mans looks like cloud from ff7 which is
like berserk because i think if i was
definitely inspired berserk for sure
gotta do the gut style okay i'm
definitely gonna get ambushed
yeah no
it's one of these games
okay so a lot of these dungeons like
this you're gonna find grave glove words
so you really do want to pick up the
items you find even if you don't see
something immediately there
just as a heads up
just joining which character class is he
what's up man um
stripper class yes indeed i am the
stripper class
i'm playing as vagabond but again your
class doesn't matter very much in a game
it's just oh that's right this
check out this trap
i want to show this trap actually okay
look at the spikes at the top
right
so
see those spikes there
if you stay on and don't know where to
go hey come on
i gotta trap the show
yeah it's gonna like slam you into that
no no no no okay great i thought it was
gonna go back down that's why i did that
there we go
so there's stuff like this too there's
like cool traps there's like secrets so
it turns out you're actually supposed to
go down here uh like lots of exploration
to do in dungeons
might want to enlarge the cam window no
i'm trying not to um
pratheric i'm trying not to show my face
as much
like i'd rather people see the game uh
my face is just there as an aside you
know it's not the game is more important
than me
so i actually have specifically put my
camera in the far right corner so i
wouldn't be interrupting gameplay as
much as like little as possible
all right
is it out right now it'll it'll be out
uh
i think i heard that steve you can get
in like four hours
but for ps5 and all that the console is
it comes out 25th at midnight i believe
so
uh if you're a console dude like me
since i am a console pro through and
through
i've nothing against ps
or pc it's just honestly surprised
because that's what i grew up with i was
playing consoles i also played pcs as
well for like adventure games and
rts's but
i was always more of a console guy
so that's just my preference
also i like playing on a tv i mean i
guess you could hook a pc up to a tv but
i just i don't know i like the setup i
like not need to worry about
it's just for me man
how's elder ring so far well i've played
75 hours and it is magnificent
um honestly
[Music]
if it doesn't get game of the year i
know it's february but if it doesn't get
game of the year i'm going to be very
upset
um yeah it is truly magnificent
i thought there were limited of these
guys but now i'm realizing that they
might be unlimited
so it's probably dumb that i'm just yeah
yeah
i'm over this i'm over it let's get out
of here
uh
well that's not true and you should
watch the digital foundry performance
analysis
i guess they'd probably be good for that
where to find this sword it is in caled
i will show you on the map where to find
it so earlier in the game i ran through
to show how to find it earlier in the
stream
uh okay i can't right now because i'm in
combat as soon as i can open my map i'll
show you guys where i found the sword so
you can you can get this sword
[Music]
again i am way too low level for it
right now
but um
yeah
here's the boss room that i just opened
up
okay so
here's my map so far again this is just
a tiny section of the map there's like
caleb all the way to the right to the
north uh west you have all of leona
northeast you've got atlas plateau
you've got the mount gilmore to the left
yeah i've been other areas to the top
right it's like
insane and there's so much in each one
oh sorry and then uh
see this roth view balcony right here in
the start of caleb it's around this area
you'll find a treasure chest in a
carriage and that's what's got this
weapon that i'm using right now so
hope that helps
oh look another archery burial watchdog
but this time he's got friends
i forgot that was the boss that was in
here so yeah sometimes you will see
bosses that repeat but there's not too
much of it like it's not to the point
where i would
i wouldn't worry about it honestly
because it is pretty limited in how
often you see bosses
and it's like when you do see them
there's some twist to it like this one
who's got his buddies in it
but there are there are so many bosses
in the game that's why i'm saying don't
worry about it you're still gonna find
plenty
trying to take care of the bros first
come on man come on
really
the final ones oh my god he's doing this
thing i gotta get away
get away get away
okay there we go now i can focus on him
ah [ __ ] i really i just remember that i
can only attack him once with this sword
it's too slow
i'm gonna do two anyways i'm getting
greedy
but with this attack specifically you
can only go once okay he's doing this
thing i'm gonna
untarget so i can hit him and keep on
getting away from him
which i failed anyways
stay safe stay safe my dudes
you know it's not smart
i'm too impatient man these games are
about patience
toxicity in this chat is sad
yeah i don't understand man like this
game you should be like it is
incredibly good and people should really
be excited about this like this is
easily going to be the game of the year
it's going to be like a game of the
decade too i think
like you are seeing
one of
the best games that come out in a long
time
um
just throwing that out there
so
defeated thank you thank you guys i
appreciate it
got him
so now we can keep on working on this
build
it's coming man it's coming to fruition
so close
it's so close
i think i need 30 right 31 ah 31 okay
actually i think this spot is gonna be
better no nevermind this spot's better
okay
[ __ ] don't want to be happy i
know
it really feels that way
i don't get it but whatever
do you have tons of markets in the game
no
there are only rundown ruins of towns uh
you will find npcs and characters about
in various areas
uh and there is a stronghold that you
can go to essentially and there's like a
couple places i guess with like npc like
a allotment of npcs but in general the
answer is no
so
oh actually i don't care about that
watchtower i'm not gonna go there
so
yeah
sorry at 11 36 okay
x runs smooth
i know souls fans are going to hate me
for saying this but i wish the game had
an easy move for us to get easily
frustrated
here's the thing
and this is always my argument
personally
these games basically do have an easy
mode it's just not given to you
it's just not told to you
uh it's their rpg so you can level up a
lot
to like prepare yourself for areas and
make them trivialize them and make them
a lot easier
there's spirit ashes you can summon that
make them easier you can summon co-op
allies to help you out through every
area and boss
so it's just like
it's more of the fact that
in game they built in mechanics that are
much more clever than just adding an
easy mode
that make it so you can make the game
far easier for yourself
uh and that's that's really what it is
it's like if you want that kind of mode
it's in the game it's just it's built in
and you can do that so it's like
it's kind of i think more frustrating to
me to be like
why take this easy way out that's just
not genuinely interesting or good game
design
when they built in that mechanic with a
really good level of game design already
ah
that's my opinion on it
that's why i don't particularly like
that discussion
um because there are so many built-in
ways to play the game to make it easier
if that's what you want
um
as it's an rpg as there's builds that
you can use as there's spirit ashes in
this one that you can summon that
basically
make a lot of the bosses wait more
simple if you want that make them less
aggressive because they'll take off the
focus on you
um
there's just so much of that in this
game
that
uh and then again there's co-op and
summons you can summon people in to help
you and play it with bros who'll help
you out so like
there's a lot of that already there and
you can like level up your weapons level
up your spirit ashes and things like
that
uh it's like looking at a jrpg and
saying why don't those have easy modes
in a way
uh because they're that's it's built in
hellblade 2 looks insane i am very
excited for hellblade 2.
all right so here we find another church
uh this is going to be nice because
again the churches that you find not all
of them but a lot of them are going to
have the tears basically
so we get a sacred tier
uh how big is the open world compared to
like breath of the wild uh i'd say it's
a
similar size
if i were to go off my top of my head
uh i mean they're both massive so i'd
say it's probably similar in size to
breath a lot but i think there's more to
do in this game that's the thing
i mean like look i love breath of the
wild i love exploring breath of the wild
it is a very good game
but a lot of this stuff can feel samey i
feel like like the shrines that you find
i feel like every shrine here like not
trying but like every dungeon here while
they start to get a little samey and
like oh this is what the
a catacombs gonna look like a catacomb
the
there's a lot more variety in what you
find and the things you find there are
much more unique and
interesting so
yeah
all right so this is uh one of the minor
her trees
and they're typically guarded by these
guys or tree avatars that's not always
the case but a lot of them are
and her tree avatars really like to mess
you up let me tell you
uh yeah they can be pretty tough and the
fact that i'm using a slow sword not the
best
but mainly the thing with them that you
got to watch out for is that they will
take out your steed really fast and when
they do
uh they'll follow up with an attack
that's gonna stop on you and like crush
all right so i'm healing right now for
my steam not for me but i'm trying to
get my steam some more help
all right
and i'm doing such a little damage to
him i'm like what's going on
here we go let's
get that attacking
uh for sure breath of the wild is great
but i totally agree sequel hopefully
swatches yeah i hope so and i am very
excited for this equal to breath for a
while like
i love breath of the wild it is an
amazing game but that's like the one
criticism i could say about it
um
whereas this game i find exploration to
be more rewarding in the sense of what
you're finding like breath of the wild
is very rewarding in its exploration and
just how
like fun exploration is it's just fun to
explore in that game
and all the sights that you're going to
see
but in terms of like the actual rewards
you get typically it's not as rewarding
whereas this game
is oh i might die here
oh my god
i got greedy and it screwed me over well
at least you know what i did on purpose
to show you guys a steak america
yeah this is a good month for games it's
an amazing month for game compared this
game to witcher 3. they're very
different beasts
which are three side quests are all
about like story lines and stuff like
that they're gonna lead you down these
interesting story paths
uh this game is more like this game is
honestly in terms of its opening world
is much more comparable to bright the
wild
so i really don't think
uh witcher 3 is a good comparison in any
way
they're very very different games so i
mean this is a very very different game
from breath of the wild
but that's a much better comparison
so
yeah that's what i'll say on that
oh god my horse is about to die
and i had like a good no death run going
for a little while in the beginning of
this stream but
you know
it's a souls game what you're gonna do
from software game
it's an elden game
whatcha gonna do
stop trying to kill my horse jerk
my horse is about to die and that's not
good
funny
visceral
there we go
yeah like i said when the horse dies
you're like you're kind of screwed with
this guy
all right
yeah and part of the reason i'm able to
mostly steamroll through these bosses is
because i've already like
you know i figured out their move sets
by now
through playing enough
and even then like as you saw some of
them still take me out so
yes i love that attack it's just easy to
get out of the way of him
punish him
oh my god my horse my horse
all right let's be smart i'm like last
time
and all right
get away get away from these
okay
no no
there we go
all right earth tree avatar done and
okay so you're gonna you're gonna see
this uh what you get for these guys near
the minor archerys is you're going to
get tears opaline bubble tear and
crimson burst crystal tier for this
specific one
what these tiers are going to do
is these are what you mix into your
flask of physic
so
slowly uh this one
restores hp over time
uh this one provides significant damage
negation
but again you can only use your wondrous
physique flask once
basically
so yeah
the backgrounds are so gorgeous i can't
stop staring at them yeah i agree
have you been the main quest can you
tell us if it's very enjoyable or good
etc so
i am about 75 hours into the main quest
and i'm basically at the end of it but i
haven't beaten it yet
so i'm very close
but i have not beaten it yet so i'm just
i like basically i could if i want to
right now
but um
i'm trying to do a lot of side stuff
first because there's so much side stuff
that i want to see and discover and all
that
and i have a lot of side stuff left to
do so i'm very close but yes the game is
magnificent throughout it holds up the
whole time and somehow it feels really
well balanced the whole time too as you
keep on progressing in my opinion
all right let's see how much how many
rooms does this thing give me
is it gonna be enough where i can level
up my weapon
because that's really what i want right
now
yes
and another one's gonna cost 1600 which
i probably can't afford but let's find
out
how much this might give me 800 above
one oh okay so i can
nice
so for market i'll try parrying and if
that doesn't go well i'm gonna now have
a more viable great sword
i still need two more levels for my
greatsword to even be able to like
um there we go
all right so i still yeah so now it's at
a high enough level where i have to go
find a npc to level up my great sword
once he has passed plus three that's
when i have enough runes and or stuff
anyways but
let's go back to market
uh is this game a continue to dark souls
it's a brand new story it's a brand new
lore the mechanics are similar
final fantasy oh you're just that's
right you're just trolling
troll boy
oh wait but i remember what i need to do
to before i forget
one
uh okay first of all for adding a charge
now i need two golden seeds
so that changes over time i'm going to
increase them out my last replenish
and uh
i guess i'll try to parry
i don't think it's gonna go well but
let's try it out
let's see
i never even thought to try against him
so that'll be exciting
uh can you talk about the main quest
story some is it good or just in the
background it's basically in the
background like most souls games
i mean like i think it's [ __ ]
i was trying to dodge and accidentally
press the wrong button
yeah part of this is just gonna be i
need to figure out the timing for the
pairing that's why at least i know the
dodge roll timing
okay
no the dodge whatever
i'll just try to fight him normally i
guess
and if i get an opportunity to try i'll
try like with this second phase
specifically to start um
to start like using my stuff
or sorry sorry to try to start burying
he'll be out in three hours nice
yeah i'm playing really really poorly
against him because i'm just trying to
like be close
yeah he always punishes you for trying
to heal
by doing this
like i said the next phase i'm going to
try to do the uh
what you guys recommended
yeah you can see i have some of this
stuff down but this is the phase where
he gets
really difficult
i really want to try a barrier here
oh crap
that's the thing you said
to switch hand your weapon you have to
press the same button used to attack so
that's where like sometimes i mess up
i need time to figure it out i'm going
to go back to my other weapon for now
can you cut off this tail and get a
sword drop not that i'm aware of
so far looks a lot easier than dark
souls 3 or bloodborne is it just me
i think part of the fact is that i've
played the game at this point most of
the beginning three times so i can kind
of steamroll through it
and honestly it is not easier i promise
you the further you get you will realize
it's not easier
um
let me see something can i equip
anything else
okay
one more thing
it's not easier though um
i mean obviously with the open world you
can explore and make the game
a little easier for yourself but not
it's still not like
easy
and there are uh there are ways that
with accessibility that you can make
this game easier for yourself but again
like
i wouldn't call this game easier
i've honestly struggled with certain
points more than either of those games i
would say
morgan do your
do an attack that i like
the stream is low quality a gaming
channel jack hardware disappointing
uh it's
you know how that has to do with the
internet right it's just internet speed
and i'm at home like what do you want me
to say man my internet speed is what i
have what they give me
there's only so much i can do for that
i'm sorry
so
yeah
doing my best with my internet speeds
blame time warner if you don't like it
oh i forgot to mix the wondrous physique
thing and i was wondering why i wasn't
healing me a bunch i forgot to do that
okay
hey i want you to jump at me please
oh my god i knew i dodged earlier on
that
jack of the defense
the thing is i actually like godric more
i find godric easier which is funny i'm
like man godric needs a fang i mean it
could just be because i don't know how
to furry time this guy honestly
but that's i don't so i don't know what
can i say
i like i need time to figure it out i
just don't want to figure that out on
stream
there
yeah sorry guys
if i don't win i i don't want to like be
stuck too long at certain bosses so
at least it shows you guys that the game
isn't like easy some people are claiming
all right last keel last deal
at least he did this one which i feel
like
get him on
right now my heater is going way too hot
so i'm like burning up and that's part
of my stress i think
i'm honestly just trying to bait him
into an attack i know i can hit right
now so i don't
yo
there we go
oh no oh
no went for that opening and
yeah that one like swinging attack i'm
so bad at it i'm so bad at
yes thank you thank you margaret that is
what i'm looking for
all right
give me another hammer bros and
i think we're good maybe
unless he
all this crap oh my god oh my god get
out of my way fence
market stop it i got a stream got it oh
god
other hammer bros
thank you
doing another attack
boom
all right
i was terrified i was honestly terrified
okay if you beat him you get a talisman
pouch
and that's the really interesting thing
from him
so
uh is this game game multiplayer or is
this separate it's all multiplayer if
you want
i can't heal myself
i have zero i i couldn't heal myself i
had zero heals left so i had no way to
heal myself
uh is there an incentive using a fur
call anything around other than for
summoning i'm worried non-sensual pvp is
gone
i'm obviously not sir gut store let's go
exactly
thank you guys thank you
uh i said he wants to play from game on
pc kid that's what i said okay i'm not i
didn't see what you're talking about
guess what
there it is
i can now wield my sword properly
so actually i want to see if i have any
uh i have two smithing stones of two
that's nice but
bam
i now have
enough to wield it properly with my
strength
boom it's not i mean i have to go for
endurance so i can put more armor
but uh here we're gonna go here so i can
level up my sword again your sword looks
awesome thank you king midas
nicely done dave i appreciate it captain
steve
uh yeah so like
this is the soul's experience yeah it's
like that that feeling
oh here's d
until you get a death root i don't think
you can progress further with this
storyline
this is diallos whose storyline will
continue on later
uh
here we have our smith i don't know why
anyone would compare him to andre it's
just a blacksmith it's nothing like
andre so i don't know i remember seeing
that comparison floating around
he now
uh he can actually strengthen your your
stuff beyond what the smithing stone can
do which is what i'm going to do here
so we're going to do that as you guys
saw i got another talisman pouch which
makes me so i can equip more talismans
uh for beating
margaret
this lady
she might look a little familiar to you
if you really think about it i don't
know might look familiar
what's in this 2013 council of wars
yeah people are kind of like acting like
that you know what i guess i should talk
to him a little bit
about it he's an interesting character
who i i'm not gonna go into right now
that's but he's an interesting character
uh
something about patches i'm not is this
on the new patch uh it is yes at least i
got a patch yesterday that automatically
updated i don't know if there's another
one
here's corn he sells you priests he's a
member of the holy order
the holy order basically believes in all
this stuff about the elder ring and he
sells you all the priestly stuff
so he's going to be your dealer for that
for a while at least
uh
okay
let's go ahead and go into stormville um
i think i have like one more hour to
stream
annoying streamer thanks lord bob why
because i talk
why please tell me why
okay so anyways i'm gonna go ahead and
see if i can get to uh godric and bum
rush it there for you guys
can you talk about the story some and
maybe give it a one out of ten i don't
fully know the story so it's hard for me
to tell you that because i'm still
trying to figure things out that's kind
of what i do is i like make i've made a
lot of lore videos
from software games over the years
i made like eight years
of lore videos at this point this patch
is the thief in the game
uh yes patches in the game
uh okay
come over here
so he can open the main gate for us so
we're gonna do that
wait a second you know what though that
will screw me over for a side quest
because it doesn't matter if i screw
over the side quest
in fact it might get be good for a guide
oh wait whoops i was just doing his uh
i was going through his dialogue so fast
i didn't like do the thing i was
supposed to you slip
no i'll use the main gate
it's actually better to go through the
main gate at night because the guys are
sleeping i think
a lot of the hype seems manufactured nah
nah
nah
you good bro nice to meet you thanks
guys i appreciate it
i appreciate it thank you hey fellas how
do i put the game on easy
i'll tell you how get someone like co-op
get get a buddy to co-op with you
that's how you do
i it the new passenger the performance
or at least on pc that i'm not sure of
because i'm playing on uh ps5
so i think at night these guys are
sleeping
okay i guess i was wrong i didn't know
that that was just a guess because i
thought i went through at night once
they were shooting at me like this
so this is the thing about the main gate
is you got to deal with these guys
you can still go through though
which i'm going to attempt to do here
and you want to like hug the walls also
once you get through there's another
side of grace like literally right here
so
oh [ __ ] oh my god i'm so stupid i can't
believe i did that
easy most fearsome as a cop yeah pretty
much
uh
use your summons and co-op if you want
if you really want that
uh how you want your own pace pick what
you think looks good yeah so that's the
other thing like play at your own pace
and if you're having trouble explore
more
there's like areas that are way
difficult here and there's areas that
are easier depending on your level so
like really like try to explore find
things you can deal with
um that's like the main thing i can tell
you is like explore find things you can
deal with
um
if you're really struggling use spirit
ashes
summon people in to help you there's a
lot of ways
yeah
you died you got it can we see the great
move sword move set new now can fully
because i finally have the strength to
use it
okay so it's pretty
that's your r1
here's your
r1 two-handed
this is gonna be your r2
so there's your r2
here's your r2 two-handed
so pretty similar
uh
and here's your l2 for what that's just
what i have equipped right now l1 is
that
uh yeah l2 is just to use your uh
whatever ashford you have
is it better than breath of the wild
uh they're very different it depends on
what you like um
they're so different it's hard to
compare
uh
you know what actually i'm gonna go the
other way
just because there's a thing i want to
find that's the other way
do i want to find it
yeah whatever
let's go the other way for now
not that i can't go through there
actually the main gate is faster for
game through to godric i think but
this way is pretty fast too since i know
what to do
is there an easy difficulty again
no there's not like a difficulty setting
that you can just turn on
where the hell did i set that marker
oh i accidentally turned whoops
uh
yeah so there's not like an easy mode
that you can just turn on
there is however um
ways to make the game a lot easier for
yourself
for example
okay for example see this right here
that's a summoning pool
when you turn that on if you're playing
online that's where people's signs will
be left if they want who can help you
out so it makes it really easy to find
people to help you out
and uh yeah
who the [ __ ] is comparing this game to
breath of the wild honestly i really
think it's a decent comparison
it really feels like breath of the wild
meets dark souls in a lot of ways in a
lot of good ways so like that's not a
negative thing it's just an easy way to
describe it because the exploration and
math
is kind of breath of the wild it's just
like you know an easy way to compare
something
i think it's like a valid comparison
honestly
um just in the sense of like how
exploration in the game works
beyond that yeah it's very different and
very soulsy but like
uh it still is very unique
um
it's basically like
he was talking miyazaki's looked at
broke a while and said i can do that
but in my own way
how many players can go up together i'm
not sure i've i think i've heard three
but i honestly don't know
uh i really don't think calling it dark
souls 4 is fair at all if i'm being
honest
so that's that's just me though i don't
think it's fair i think it's it's very
uh of its own class
and again it has its own lore unlike the
dark souls series
like when people say that it's like
calling bloodborne
dark souls four like two
when bloodborne is very unique in its
own beast
like just because it's a medieval
fantasy or dark fantasy i should say
it doesn't automatically make it that
all right so we have to go here because
there's a guy back here who's got an
item that i need
i like how he just laughs about what he
did to you he's like hahaha i got him
got him
oh this guy's normally way harder thank
you great sword
great sword just trivialized that fight
well also the fact that i've been like
leveling up a bunch
all right so there's also an item here
there's the chest
what are your thoughts on pure magic
bills honestly i haven't had time to try
it i'm like 75 hours into the main game
and i haven't had
that's just like one game and i still
haven't finished it so i haven't been
able to try magic build because i
typically like either playing strength
or dex builds personally
so yeah
what is your character warrior i'm using
vagabond as my starting class but it
doesn't matter that much i've completely
changed the leveling to make him a pure
strength build
so
yeah how hard is the game um
i mean it's comparable to dark souls and
bloodborne i'd say it's a little more
challenging but that's just because it's
my first time through it's hard for me
to really compare their different beasts
in a lot of ways
uh and the fact that like this one's
open worlds explored it
level up a little bit more and not get
so stuck but i've still found that there
are some
pretty major challenges in the game
so
i mean like for me i'd say like honestly
i think i'm
finding certain areas that i should
probably struggle more with
than either of those games
and then other parts that i think are
supposed to be difficult where i'm like
hey i got this
so i don't know
i don't think it's
um
i think it's a little harder i'd say i'd
say it's probably harder than the other
two but that's just me
so that's going to be very personal i
think for tay
but again if you're like a fan and if
you're a fan and you don't want a carter
how much harder is it than seiki though
they're very different they're very very
different
so it's hard to say like once you get
good at seikido sekiro is not that hard
but one but getting learning the
mechanics and mastering seikido i'd say
is more difficult
i'd say seikio is more difficult to
master the mechanics but once you master
i think stay here is an easier game
if that helps
so
a little bit of both i guess you could
say
um
that's just personally my take on it
yo what spell needs 70 stat i don't know
what you mean i wasn't sure who to
choose between vagabond or hero for the
strength during class kind of like hiro
has lower into faith but 11 arcane
yeah i honestly i
i should look at the hero stats i don't
know maybe i should have chosen hiro
whereas i chose vagabond
maybe that would have been smarter for
me
for the build i'm going for because i'm
going pure strength right now
i don't know which i wonder which one
has higher endurance
they're both totally viable just depends
on how you build your character what you
enjoy more yeah that's true i mean
that's the thing the starting class
really doesn't matter that much
i can't i can't state that enough for
these games
because
you're gonna level up a lot and you're
gonna completely reallocate your stats
as you play for whatever you find that
you're enjoying
so like it really it really isn't that
big of a deal what you choose and you
can do combination builds in this game
too we do like an intelligent strength
build intelligent decks build
you know
so
yeah i really don't think
that
that's something that you should worry
about too much
and that's kind of how these games are
in general
secular is good not cheap oh
sorry i'm not sure what you're talking
about there
can you find another armor for the
enchanted knight and bloodwolf
uh says he's still yes you can still
find those armors bloodwolf uh is very
much further than
in the game enchanted knight i think
isn't too far
but yeah you can find them and they also
have different names actually they're
not named the same thing interestingly
okay i'm just gonna show you guys some
exploration stuff real quick
uh just to show you guys like some of
the interesting design here because i
could roll through
this area if i wanted to
at this point and just
like bum rush it to the boss
but i think it'll be fun to show a
little bit more of the exploration just
to show it off
uh this is the legacy dungeon first
legacy dungeon by the way
they'll bleed up op for real for real yo
first of all uh there's a dude out here
with trumpet he's gonna wake up all
those guys that he saw laying down so we
want to take him out
and now you can see like the exploration
being very very uh
very from soft and like running on
ramparts things like that which is
pretty cool
stone sword key
all right
we're gonna try to take that guy out
right now hopefully
this guy is a nightmare to me so
all these hawks with blades on their
feet are nightmares in my opinion to
fight
so we're gonna take that out
ours astronomers are good for players
who like magic i'm honestly not sure i
can't i can't help you with that
unfortunately i don't know the answer
how much more of the game do you have
left um okay so on my main here i have a
giant amount like a ridiculous amount
on my main game i'm like 75 hours into
i'd guess about if i just bum rushed it
to the end without exploring anymore
i would guess about five hours
maybe even less
that's my guess i don't know if there's
another big dungeon that i haven't found
that i'm not sure of
but that's my guess is maybe like five
hours
um
but there's so much exploration i
haven't done that i want to do yet an
npc quest lines i haven't finished i'm
curious about and stuff like that
that i'm curious about
so that's why it's like hard for me to
tell you because i
i also don't know because i haven't
explored it yet but i know i'm at the
end area for sure
your starting class really just affects
early game yeah that that's basically
what it is so people i think really
worry about the starting class a little
too much
is arcane pointless i haven't used it at
all i say if you want to make sure
you're getting item drops it probably
isn't but i'd say it's probably kind of
pointless honestly
i'm hopping across there just for fun
but there's nothing here
all right let's go
this way for the drop down
so again this was just me showing off
some exploration with time you've
already spent in the game what would you
say is your favorite souls like so far
uh okay this is gonna be very personal
to everybody
so and i've played all of them a lot
this one i played the least in the sense
of like i've only gotten one play
through really and i'm
like like i said 75 80 hours into it
um
personally
my favorites dark souls one still
and then bloodborne would be my second
favorite
however that's like very very personal
to me
um
yeah like that's just that's personal to
me so like everyone's gonna be different
in that regard
and then i say this is my third favorite
so far so for me it probably goes dark
souls one bloodborne elden ring
and then dark souls three i'd say
and then demon souls
and then dark souls do i actually like
dark souls 2 a lot but um
when i replayed demon souls i actually
liked it a lot more maybe my second time
playing through made me enjoy it more
and that's the thing that i'm saying is
hard to say with this because i might do
i play those games so much i've gotten
to know them so well
that that might be part of my why i say
that
dave have you found a boss weapon yet
that is scaling on all stats like c
strength i found ones that have scaling
on three i think
at least i have three requirements i
don't know if i found one that has four
but honestly i've been pretty set on the
ones that i'm using so that's why i
can't fully answer that
um because i kind of have the weapons
i'm using speaking of which see these
somber smithing stones that i just
picked up
so you have normal smithing stones and
then somber ones and sombra ones are for
like boss weapons and stuff like that
for that type of scaling because they're
gonna have different items to use
i'll finally use the stone sword key
here
and you can see what's behind a stone
sword key now
which is basically going to be like some
goodies some special items so this guy
had the iron wet blade
oh that might be what i wanted oh my god
i think the iron wet blade might be what
makes this i can add like a strength to
it hold on let me check this that might
be exactly what i was looking for
yes you can add heavy keen oh my god
that's where it is okay that's great
that's especially good for my build i
didn't even realize that i'm glad i went
in here
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna show you guys
why that's good
uh when i get to my next shrine of grace
looks like a cool game can't wait for
sale yeah it's a very very good game uh
for sure
okay we're going to try to sneak here
because that guy is tough as nails and
i basically just want to unlock this um
shortcut here what the hell
i know this is where it is why can't i
unlock it
oh wait because it's right down there
i am stupid
is there a difference in the standard
deluxe editions i don't think so other
than maybe the deluxe edition they give
you some freebies that probably don't
matter very much
i mean i might that's my guess
but i guess i'd have to look
usually they don't matter for these
games what time is it coming out i think
in a few hours on steam from what i'm
hearing all right so i oh i don't have
enough yet to level up all right that's
fine let's do uh
first of all
before i forget
let me
uh
my sacred tear is fine i want to mix my
wondrous physique
and add the crimson burst here
and then
i'm going to go to ashes of war
and let's still use
oh i can do it with this one too that's
fun okay notice i can now choose heavy
that's going to change my scaling so i
have zero on decks but more on the
strength
and uh
for the at all right so right now for my
physical because i have better strength
scaling you can see for physical and
that's because that iron wet blade i
just got
oh man i've i need to add that to video
i should have done that for my tips
video i'll do it for the beginner's
guide i guess anyways
right now i would have i currently have
with a normal standard c scaling and
decks at e
um you can see 202 and then because my
scaling at plus 87 which is 289.
if i switch to strength purely which is
all i've been leveling up
now all of a sudden i have 186 plus 111
so that's gonna be 297 for my attack so
it's gonna uh
raise it uh okay not quite as much as i
was hoping but still a little bit right
and but that's gonna keep on going up
more and more as i level up so strength
is what i want for this
i still haven't found one that has s
scaling or a scaling to be honest but i
might not have just leveled up stuff
enough yet
so all right anyways
that's the scaling guide we're gonna go
fight a cyan grafter who's probably
gonna absolutely wreck me up but
you know that's all good
i think he
i think the thing i want is around here
actually no wait the thing i want's over
here isn't it
this is going to be the important
questline item over here i think
oh my god
get out of here dogs
okay this thing right here
the chrysalids memento is an important
quest item
uh that i want to use before godric also
some cool little details there see how
that giant's hung up there and his guts
have been ripped out
all right oh my god this guy is going to
be
a mess
even a higher level these guys are still
tough oh great at least he's doing this
attack
okay thank you for the jump attacks oh
come on
no
you jerk
all right
i just like that like jumpy attack thing
he does
that
yeah honestly i haven't really figured
him out yet
so that's why i'm like a little uh quiet
right now trying to figure my
yep
yep
oh my god i'm stuck on a wall
jesus christ okay
at least i'm still like auto regaining
health i think from my uh sacred tears
class
or my wondrous physics class
oh god oh god oh god
when are you gonna do another jump
attack at me
oh yeah that's that's cool
there we go
now thank you
so close so close
oh god look at that he just like wrecks
me so much which is basically
like one mess up
i mean granted granted i don't have uh
any feelings like armor equipped but
still
and guess what i get for beating him
nothing
all right but at least you can pick this
stuff up highland axe
multiplayer is so uh
does it run smoothly on pc i don't know
i don't play fps for a story i watch
movies for a story i play game for
gameplay during
cutscenes i make a cup of quiche
i like when there's a good story i
appreciate when games do stories in a
way only games can do it
that's really what i look for
uh and that's why i i like the way this
person and i know this is
everyone's different personally i like
the way that dark souls tells a story
because
you it's a very
video game way to tell a story where
it's all through exploration nothing's
just handed to you
you have to like read things and find
people to discover the story
so it feels like uh they're telling a
story in a way that only games can tell
and like characters can lie to you
change the way that you're pers you
perceive things
i really think like to me this is a much
more interesting way to tell
a video game story
uh and you know cutscenes are fine and
they can be fun to watch
but
yeah for me like this is
this is more interesting storytelling
and i like games that
do storytelling and waves games only
like brother is a tale of two sons
like that game does it in a very good
way
um
yeah there's a lot of games that do
here's our first painting my guys
look at this well first painting that
i've gotten to
i still haven't found this one for real
on my own i still need to find that one
on my main game
all right
we're going to deal with this guy later
i'm just going to go find this side of
grace first which is right up here
is about to upgrade upgrade a heavy oh
my god
i didn't realize who's gonna be
is it possible upgrade heavy gray so i
wish i could read that i really want to
answer the question
i'll say you can upgrade your heavy grey
sword if that's the question but i'm not
sure if that's the question
let me get a backstab please
okay
is it possible to create a heavy gray
sword it's hella can block 100 physical
oh until it can block 100 physical
damage no i don't think it will ever do
that
okay now we're gonna go
you see strength upgrading my attack a
little more but we're gonna go endurance
now so i can start to try to equip some
armor you know
uh because that'd be nice let's see
there we go okay
now i'm just no pants wait actually hold
on
can i do that nope okay let's go back to
that then
uh okay so
i'm gonna go to storm hill shack
because remember that girl that i found
right the item that i just got it
relates to her questline
so if i talk to her now
it won't tell them i'm trying to get in
there basically this is going to
progress her uh storyline in a positive
way
so you really want to make sure you do
that also she's going to gift us a
golden
a golden seed she's i think so she goes
to the round table hold
which so now let's go to the round table
hold
and
there you find her
the round table i never knew although
i'm still looking
okay please allow him for giving me give
me the golden seat please thank you
so she's trying to figure out what she
to do
um i guess i won't spoil that
so let's go to the lift side chamber
it has ranked play that's sorry i'm like
reading the chat see if there's anything
to respond to
gotta go have a good game last all right
later tsf caesar thanks for joining man
i appreciate it
all right uh
flasks
charge to flask yes
okay
cool so
let's go ahead and go beat up godric
shall we
i'm just going to run through run
through
oh god
first of all the philly lewis here
oh god oh god oh god oh god
i wasn't able to die because i was
talking to her
we're arguing about dumb stuff don't
bother reading okay thanks kid kissimmee
okay smitty i appreciate it
oh yes i see the console war debate
got it
you know there's actually an area in
stormville castle i saw not found yet
which is interesting to me
how are you playing already from uh
d bitty honor
i guess i could say that so that's on
twitch
so i have this on
i got a review copy i'm playing review
copy i've actually been playing all week
for uh game spot
for footage for like reviews and guys
and stuff like that that we're making
so there you go that's that's
at least such a nightmare
seriously such a nightmare
does that daughter die
uh what the girl that i just found
i think she can
but i the way that i just did it was
progressing your storyline the correct
way
so
yeah
why do you
oh
honestly for these guys this weapon is
not very good you want a weapon that has
a vertical strike it's way better at
attacking these guys
come on
let me get you there we go
oh one more second okay
there we go now i can talk to the person
how you like element rings so far what's
been the most challenging enemy or area
you've encountered
uh i don't want to spoil the most
challenging enemy there's a there's two
demigods well actually one in particular
who's like whoa be proud
he was very tough a fine warrior ah the
only mistake was your choice of master
that the winds left you tarnished i am
the fellow
although i haven't met chieftain lou yet
um
so there's like
two demigods in particular who are very
tough
and one specifically who was like oh my
god it was like a very different kind of
boss fight
uh not not like um
not like the
standard one like that people get mad
about with souls
uh it wasn't but it was like a different
kind of boss fight and it was like tough
okay
so i did get a golden seed as you
probably saw but i can't use it yet
because i need two and i only have one
let's go ahead and see what this ash of
war is
and also there was actually a lift i
missed that like would have taken me
straight here
where i didn't have to go through that
area that you just saw me going through
uh also let's see what popcorn is up to
hey
we found ourselves a pop boy
and then we're gonna go to gadri
yeah that's right my great sword will
wreck all
uh-uh
okay great
so he doesn't really have like he has
goodies inside him but it's not like
the type of stuff that you need per se
um
fine arts cracked a pot and a crackpot
and that's all like
smithing stuff
and i don't think i can go here because
i think the shortcut was the other way
maybe
unless i'm wrong oh i guess this is the
shortcut okay
so this is just going to take me right
back to that other bonfire on fire sorry
sight of grace
that you saw earlier
and
this is the area i haven't figured out
how to open this to be honest
so
trying to see what's on the other side
here so i can try to figure it out
it looks like an area i've already been
to right
okay anyways
uh okay
why are you uh does anyone know
an alternate to steam
oh okay so check it out if you want you
can also summon to philly lou for this
boss fight
by the way
let's enjoy some
godric
mighty dragon
dirty true born air
lend me thy strength o kindred
deliver me unto
greater heights
can you do pairing without a shield
uh yes if you had a parrying dagger i
don't know if anything else does it but
i know perry and dagger 100 can
i don't know if you can do it with a
weapon to be honest maybe you can
actually i think you like an actual war
that's a fairy
maybe
all right
all right godrick let's do this
okay
been a while i'm trying to see if i can
remember his moveset
all right that's actually one i didn't
want to
attacking during i kind of got lucky to
be honest
all right this one's one that i want to
attack
i just like if i could have gotten two
attacks
because i know i can get it in there and
i have time for it
what is this one all right one two
slow
fast and then the real one boom
oh god
bam
how is he not
staggered yet
that's what's surprising to me
all right godric
which one's it gonna be you can also
shoot stuff out at you here but the
rolling attack's better because you can
actually like get him during it
crap
yeah so
he can like get you pretty easily there
there we go that's the stagger
oh no it's not the stagger i take it
back let me kill myself here
this is part two the boss fight
why just get the customers over i'm
sorry wolf i'll do the this one is from
it's because the custom was in all the
trailers and we've already seen it but
i'll be quiet
truest of dragons
lend me thy strength
[Music]
all right
bear witness as i roll through that
wait why did i do that that was stupid
i'm good okay
i'm gonna do another and i'll run in for
the attack
oh crap oh crap why did i do that i'm
getting stupid this space is actually a
little
here we go
yeah so like the nice thing about this
phase is like he's pretty easy to get
through that stuff
when he starts using his dragon it's
like oh thanks
man i appreciate the dragon
actually i don't know what this dragon
one is
oh i see
oh crap
right as i was saying the dragon's easy
of course he does that
oh my god
i'm so mad at myself
wow
that was i was destroying him until that
oh well
that's the game
it's more just funny that he like as
soon as i was making fun of his fire
he's like oh yeah
oh yeah you're gonna make fun of my fire
i just can't believe i didn't stagger
him once that's like shocking to me
so there's that one
my bad
oh see so there he's not doing a roll at
least you guys have to see that right
i died on purpose so you see morgan
all right
i thought i missed the timing on that
only tarnished
even to graft may not break the [ __ ] out
after doing so good
man that's the game it's all good
and now i just got like crushed
i'm a little mad at myself that would
have been cool if i just beat him that
first attempt i'm like oh man
i've been so sick
now okay
right
it's because i'm getting a little greedy
to be honest i should be only attacking
once on some of these i'm not
all right please do the rollie
holy pull the attack
okay so this is gonna be one two
three
four and then five bam got it
oh i didn't have any stamina left i was
trying to dodge
that's my own fault though
i found going to the right when he does
that's the better way to do it by the
way
one hand
yeah okay come on dude do a better
attack
thank you
oh here we go now i got oh
keep on thinking i got him staggered and
i'm not
carry on me with the jokes is that
really a joke saying roly-poly attack
all right
oh nice
oh [ __ ]
i forgot about that attack
and that's going to the left that you
want to dodge
i'm nice okay
i'm only going to do once
one attack each time now
be a little bit smarter about it since i
died last time
all right
one two
oh this is different because he has the
dragon arm
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] last time he got me
something to be smart
i mean if you're next to him man you can
just like wreck him during that but i
wasn't so
all right
and to the left oh whoops messed up my
timing
we got this almost
um
i i didn't heal there because i thought
i could get away i should have been
running instead of uh
attacking
uh i have a review copy
so
that's right right now i'm gonna be
doing double attacks because i don't
care
i thought he was going to do the rollie
poll
you died yeah i'm sorry guys i was so
close that first try
it is fun playing with no armor though
oh man
i can do it
he didn't do the whole thing
just because i can hit him you know
and i'm gonna get away so i don't get
screwed there
oh my god
such graves threw me off of my timing
exotic graphics asked how did i get the
great sword
okay let's see
greatsword is in caled around the rocky
balcony
uh and i happen to know where to go so
see now i'm getting mad at myself like
the first death i was like yeah whatever
and i'm like why didn't i just meet him
there
that sucks
especially because i feel like all these
guests i'm having are like dumb deaths
and like man like
things stupid
like that last one i have the timing
down for it
so it's like you know it's a little
frustrating
there we go gone this time with it at
least
okay one two
three four and the final one boom
yeah the real problem with this weapon
is that it takes so much stamina
oh crap oh crap
messing up my timings
i'm like going a little too early on
things
boom
oh no damn it every time i'm like i
staggered him
okay
this time i don't go for two
oh whoops that's right i forgot about
this
unfortunately that's usually a good time
to attack but i had to play oh right
right
now what oh damn it
i wasn't close enough
to punish him for that
what the hell
why am i screwing my timing now
what's wrong with me
i forgot about that again
okay
[Music]
one
two
yo
i'm not healing these i'm
slowly restoring health i don't want to
waste my stuff
not gonna be dumb
here we go
oh crap not really apparently
oh crap this is where he's gonna have
like the homing one huh oh no he did
that oh no he didn't
okay there we go got the timing of it
down this time
i wish i could have gone next to him
there
yeah i just had to do that unfortunately
so i got no more heals left so we'll see
how this goes
i need to get close to him he's not
letting me
all right here we go finally
yo
no no
nice thank you doctor
i shouldn't have done that
all right here we go bam
done
all right
got him
no healing items left that's when it's
the time
so i got my first great room
and remembrance of the grafted which is
how you get the uh boss soul stuff
and i can level up my endurance a little
bit
uh that was too hard for me again you
can summon people in and there was a
summon i could do even offline that i
chose not to do and you can use spirit
ashes which make it a lot easier
all right let's level up my endurance a
whole bunch see if that makes it so i
can put on any more armor
no for that how about now okay now i can
put on my night armor at least okay
yeah the gust build is the way to go
okay
uh
next we're going to get the supremery
grape
just jumped in can you show stats sure
uh to the right you can see actually no
let me go to the level up screen will be
easier to see there
yeah i was basically not wearing much
armor it's just like to be guts
okay so
level up okay so you see 15 vigor 10
mind
i'm really pumped up in strength right
now and i'm starting to build up my
endurance
uh this is all very specifically
so i can use this great sword that i
want to go get at the very beginning
uh so i was trying to make it so i could
do this greatsword build
what's up ray allen
you got it you got it man oh uh
something fun that happens for killing
him
over there
what goes around comes around he had an
ugly heart
an uglier countenance and met the
ugliest events eh
nothing is worse than having heavy armor
i totally agree with that sentiment
all right so now we're going to pop into
leonia so you guys realize
you can go to leonia again this is part
of where they made the game
easier for new people
you can go to lyonia
oh you know what i should go back here
i'm not allowed to use my weapon so
usually that means there's npcs
huh
in my own game i mean see if anything's
happened
so anyways
um
now i can there
leonia what was i saying oh
you can actually this is one way to get
to leonia but there's also a skip in the
like on the side of the castle you can
go to
full havel set is so great
shibriri is grape
interesting
a yellow oozing eyeball of the infirm
the surface is shriveled inside the
squishy give to the blind maiden to
guide her to the distance light so
all right i say this is okay it's been
like i think i started streaming around
nine so it's been about four hours for
godric
as well as like some mini side stuff so
not too bad eh not too bad
so now we're at the journey of the lakes
and eventually a maiden does show up
there but here's bach good to see you i
don't know what makes her show up though
and retrieve my please allow me to play
so bach is awesome he's gonna be our
seamstress
so see how like i can make it so uh it
doesn't have the cape that's the altered
version the thing is you can alter stuff
on your own but it can cost money or
runes but he does it for free
mass do you ever i would well i don't
ask i am you so yeah anyways please
yeah one time someone appeared for me
there and i wonder how you make it
appear
if you could change or add something to
the game what would it be
i honestly got nothing i got nothing
so yeah i got nothing sorry
uh okay so i we dropped 20 hours of or
sorry 20 minutes of footage or i dropped
that for a game spot
of leonia and this is actually part of
what we dropped was right here and this
npc
this guy you're tarnished so he's uh he
got expelled from the academy of riyadh
essentially
around the time they closed their gates
and if you give him just 10 runes which
is like nothing
he'll sell some sorceries to you
he also asks for and tells you how to
get him which is to get a one stone key
and that he wants one
but from there you're kind of like how
do i find a glintstone key
uh
and you never know so yeah
basically but still
he'll tell you about that you also find
here another sacred tier so again for
your estes flasks
big sword hell yeah i'm going with the
guts build man
going with the guts build
all right
okay so let's see let me rest here again
i'm going to add that sacred tear to my
flask to make you heal me for more
and okay
at this point let's see i i don't have
too much more time i can stream
what happens if you swing at him
honestly i don't know i think he dies
but he
it's kind of like might as well just do
his quest line in my opinion
uh
yeah
so
you can see now our map expanding even
more but or actually it hasn't because
i've got a math fragment let me go get
the map fragment i can start to show you
the map getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger
where the hell is the way down
sometimes i just said all day and dark
souls remastered in the dark
cavernouries and invade guys in the
pitch black
amazing
sometimes i like to just
roll through
and punish things
wait a second
i think that this isn't going to take me
where i want to go
oh this is the other way this is the way
back
so remember i said like you can get to
stormville you can pass through
stormville castle without killing godric
to get to the yernia this is the other
side of the path but this is the path
that you would take
which lets you wrap around
but yeah let's go back to uh uranium so
it's going the wrong way
berserk sword yep exactly that's why i
want to go grab it
i'm all about that berserk sword it
looks exactly like it too
it's like it looks exactly like the
dragon slayer
so i love it
do i go to get down i'm trying to
remember
you know i guess i could do that way
okay
drop down the groovestones
try to expand out the map a little bit
okay
where are the stones
once again i'm not finding it what am i
doing
oh there we go okay there's one
oh
[ __ ]
time for some fall damage
how do you like the game from flying
right rygen i've heard mixed things i
love it i on it i think it's magnificent
in fact i'll be mad if you don't get
game of the year
was that the final boss of the entire
game gravity it was the final boss of
the entire game actually
you know sometimes things change at
night like i said so let's see if
there's anything different here
no maybe come okay
okay
but yeah gravity is op as always
are my souls
souls runes whatever
others okay
uh yeah i'm not playing on a ps5
you recommend picking up every crafting
material does it clear your inventory
yeah i say pick it all up there are
times that it does come in handy
especially for like
making stuff that gives you poison
resistance in particular is uh and that
yeah see there's the fall damage
but yeah making stuff
to negate poison damage in particular is
something that i definitely like
use it for
so
like i recommend it for that at the very
least
this was ridiculous ridiculously amazing
am i right
all right so
again when you don't have the map you
can see this thing right there that's
where the map fragment is so that's what
i'm looking for
also cytographs right here
yeah like it's so fluid too with the
horse i love how horse riding works in
this game
getting on it like fluidly or getting
off of it it's just so quick and
it just feels good
all right so
um that fragments down this way
and you know like each of these map
fragment areas are massive so like again
you have to keep in mind too
that for a lot of this stuff that i'm
rolling through i'm skipping a lot
there's so much to explore explore in
all these areas
uh i just happen to be like rolling
right through
here we go
give me that matte fragment
that's somewhere around here oh there it
is okay
oh
kill them
you're failing me great sword your ultra
great sword
after character customization can you
re-edit your character
yes but you have to find a specific
character to do it and the amount of
times you can do it is limited all right
so check it out
uh there you go this is again i've now
expanded the map
but just a little bit right so you can
see to the right there's so much for me
to find up here and to the left there's
a lot to find
so like i'm still like
expanding it and there's so much in each
section
it is truly wild how much there is
so
this game was hype i'm buying it it's
incredible
uh yeah the game is not an mmo while you
can play it cooperatively online
it's not an mmo
um
as you can see i'm just not playing with
people right now there's no one here
uh
yeah
nothing else to say on that i guess
so all right i'm actually going to be
wrapping up here but i will show you
guys one thing
this warpy warp
there's a bunch of warps like this
throughout the game
so
yeah i've actually got to get going uh
for a podcast talking about album rings
so
and look here we are learning of the
lakes
we found a quick warp
to the front but we can't get in it's
sealed
so guys
uh thank you so much for joining me i
appreciate it this has been a lot of fun
streaming for you guys and with you guys
and i hope you guys enjoyed
uh can you go everywhere you can see yes
you can go everywhere you can see
everywhere
um okay so here meeting place map
you found a simple map check your
inventory and you see that if i examine
the seal you cannot proceed without the
clint stone key
that's to get into real lucaria and look
here again like this whole section i
just warped to i haven't even gotten
them like the way to properly explore
right so all of this has tons and tons
of dungeons throughout
sites of grace dungeons areas explore
really cool areas to find
like leonia which i did earlier i still
haven't finished leonia
like this area is a giant section i
haven't explored at all with tons of
dungeons and things to find there in
towers same with this area of mist wood
uh kylie or caleb is massive kale has
its own region so leonia or sorry limb
grave limb grave is this entire section
is considered limb grave that i'm
circling right now and it is huge
uh leonia up to the left is massive as
well and so is kaylid
and there's basically two more areas
like that that are hugely massive if not
like more it's just it is massive
so anyways
thank you guys so much for the time uh
that map by the way that i picked up you
can find here at the meeting place map
so that's an important clue
and that's everything so guys i'm gonna
say peace out i hope you guys enjoyed
this guts version build that we had
going here
and uh yeah
that's good that's it man uh yeah again
i'm i'm dave dave control and uh
i'll be posting lots of stuff guides
uh lore videos breakdowns things like
that on gamespot
uh i've also
made tons of lore videos over the past
eight years for my personal channel on
like dark souls dark souls 2 3
bloodborne i've been making that stuff
for a long time so
uh i hope you guys enjoyed
uh yeah and like i am super hyped for
this game i hope you guys are hyped too
so
see you guys later
bye
you